aber es geht jetzt bereits hier fliegen
weiter Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit ist
aufgerufen worden von Karl Lauterbach
das er hat nur noch 24,5 Milliarden Euro
zur Verfügung im vergangenen Jahr waren
es
64,36 Milliarden warum dieses Minus ganz
logisch da ging es um die Bekämpfung der
Pandemie
30,08 Milliarden im vergangenen Jahr und
in diesem Jahr sind für die
corona-folgen 1,2 Milliarden nur noch
eingeplant und der erste Redner ist der
Vorsitzende des Haushaltsausschusses
hellgrauen von der CDU
wir beraten den Einzelplan des
Bundesministeriums für Gesundheit und
der größte Posten ist traditionell der
Zuschuss zur gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung
die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung
erhält in dem kommenden Jahr neben dem
standardzuschuss weitere zwei Milliarden
Euro und darüber hinaus wird es trotzdem
erforderlich sein dass der
Krankenversicherungsbeitrag wir reden ja
eigentlich in diesen Tagen in diesem
Haus sehr viel darüber dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger entlastet werden
müssen der durchschnittliche
Krankenversicherungsbeitrag wird zum
kommenden Jahr um 0,3% steigen das heißt
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden nicht
mehr sondern weniger Netto vom Brutto
haben und das macht zum ersten deutlich
dass die GKV finanzstabilisierung die im
Gesetz des Bundesministers vorgesehenes
eigentlich nur ein marginalen
teilbeiträgt der Bundeshaushalt muss
mehr leisten und die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger müssen mehr leisten die GKV
finanzstabilisierung bleibt weit hinter
dem zurück was eigentlich erforderlich
ist
große Sorgen haben in diesen Tagen die
Krankenhäuser der
Bundesgesundheitsminister hat selber in
seiner letzten Rede hier darauf
hingewiesen dass bereits 40 Prozent
unserer Krankenhäuser
Liquiditätsprobleme haben und deshalb
hat eine
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auch
angekündigt dass es ein härtefallfonds
geben soll sechs Milliarden im kommenden
und zwei Milliarden im Jahr 2024 die den
Krankenhäusern und Pflegeeinrichtungen
bei den Energiepreisen helfen soll bis
heute liegt uns nichts vor
Krankenhäuser denken darüber nach ob sie
jetzt eigentlich Insolvenz anmelden
müssen oder ob sie sozusagen in der
Erwartung auf diese Hilfe von der weder
klar ist für welchen Zeitraum sie
gewährt wird noch in welcher Höhe sie
gewährt wird ob Sie darauf vertrauen
können und weitermachen können oder ob
sie sich eigentlich der fortgesetzten
Insolvenzverschleppung irgendwie
schuldig machen und deshalb ist es
allerhöchste Zeit dass die Ampel die
ihren Streit über die Frage ob das
Wirtschafts Ministerium oder das
Gesundheitsministerium das ganze
administriert beilegt sondern den
Krankenhäusern und Pflegeeinrichtungen
und Deutschland Gewissheit gibt in
welcher Höhe Sie von diesem Fond
profitieren können denn nach dem
Belastungen der letzten Jahre die die
Krankenhäuser hatten haben sie
Planungssicherheit verdient und nicht
diese fortgesetzte Untätigkeit durch den
Streit in der Ampel
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit dem
Haushaltsentwurf den die Bundesregierung
vorgelegt hat hat sie sehr klar gesagt
für uns ist Corona erledigt und hat
zunächst an vielen Stellen keine Kosten
mehr vorgesehen wir haben jetzt eine
Situation wo wir schon heute im
Haushaltsausschuss gesehen haben dass
selbstverständlich im nächsten Jahr über
die testverordnung weitere Ausgaben
erforderlich sind und deshalb ist der
eigentliche Sparstrumpf nämlich die
globale Mehrausgabe die der
Finanzminister eigentlich
verunsicherheiten im nächsten Jahr
vorhalten wollte auch schon angeknabbert
mit 1,2 Milliarden fürs Testen im
nächsten Jahr das heißt auch hier ist
nicht ausreichend Vorsorge betroffen
worden was mich aber ehrlich gesagt am
meisten mit Sorge erfüllt ist worauf ich
in vielen Gesprächen auch hingewiesen
habe dass im Haushalt des nächsten Jahr
drei Milliarden Euro vorgesehen sind für
Impfstoff Ankäufe für Corona
das ist die Folge aus den Verträgen die
die Europäische Kommission gemacht hat
und wenn man das umrechnet sind das
ungefähr 150 Millionen Impfstoffdosen im
nächsten Jahr wir könnten also 90
Prozent der Bevölkerung nächstes Jahr
damit zweimal durchimpfen in diesen
Verträgen sind wir gebunden und diese
Verträge damals am Beginn der Pandemie
zu machen damit mich da keiner falsch
versteht war richtig aber jetzt ist es
notwendig dass die Bundesregierung auf
die Europäische Kommission und die
Hersteller zugeht und eine deutliche
Flexibilisierung in diesem Verträgen
erreicht weil wenn wir in dieser
Größenordnung im nächsten Jahr
Impfstoffe kaufen dann ist bereits jetzt
absehbar dass wir mit großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass allermeiste
davon vernichten müssen und das ist
nicht nur eine finanzpolitische
Katastrophe sondern das wäre auch
unethisch in Hinblick auf die Ressourcen
wieder eingesetzt werden
was die ich ausdrücklich begrüße ist
dass die Ampelkoalition und auch vieles
davon haben wir in Anträgen deutlich
gemacht an einigen Stellen diesen
Haushalt deutlich verbessert was ich zum
Beispiel nicht verstanden habe ist dass
die Regierung angesichts der Tatsache
dass sie sich auf den Weg macht
Haschisch zu legalisieren gleichzeitig
im Bereich der Drogenprävention eine
deutliche Absenkung des Titels
vorgesehen hat und da haben wir uns mehr
vorgestellt aber es ist richtig dass die
Koalition an der Stelle auch etwas tut
und wir würden die Veränderungen im
Haushalt im Parlament jetzt wieder mehr
Geld für die Prävention im Drogenbereich
ausgehen
etwas was mich nach wie vor aber sehr
beschwert ist der Punkt dass das Thema
globale Gesundheit gerade jetzt im
Ausgang der Pandemie eines der größten
und wichtigsten Themen ist die wir
international haben das Thema ist unter
Druck Donald Trump mit seinem Versuch
Ausstieg aus der WHO hat die
internationale Gesundheit unter Druck
gesetzt auch Boris johnson war ein ein
Regierungschef der die Ausgaben in dem
Bereich zurückgefahren hat und das ist
jetzt diese Bundesregierung ist die
einen Entwurf vorliegt wo die Ausgaben
für die internationale Gesundheit um 70
Prozent abgesenkt werden das ist ein
fatales Signal in die öffentliche
Community das ist falsch und hier sitzen
viele die mit mir im Ausschuss unter
Ausschuss globale Gesundheit sind sowas
dürfen wir eigentlich nicht tun und ich
bin froh und sage auch danke dafür dass
die Koalition zumindest bei jungen Aids
und beim global hat kleine Korrekturen
vorgenommen hat also gar nicht verstehe
ist dass unser Flaggschiff der World
Health Summit bot letztes Mal die
Ampelkoalition noch gesagt hat das
stocken wir auf jetzt die Kürzung dieses
Gesundheitsministers wieder hingenommen
hat das ist falsch globale gesundheit
ist ein zentrales Zukunftsthema da haben
wir internationale Verantwortung und
deshalb können wir in der Summe diesem
Einzelplan so leider nicht zustimmen
Helge braun ist auf der Berichterstatter
der cdu/csu er war hier der erste Redner
zum Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit und
Wolfgang hat mittlerweile das Präsidium
übernommen und hat jetzt angekündigt die
nächste Rednerin Svenja Stadler die
berichterstatt drin der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
für den Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Gäste auf
den Tribünen und vor den Bildschirmen
als erstes möchte ich mich bedanken ich
möchte mich bedanken bei den
mitberichterstattern und vor allen
Dingen bei Paula piota und Carsten klein
für die konstruktive und vor allen
Dingen vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit in
dieser Zeit das ist nicht einfach
gewesen und deshalb danke da und auch
natürlich an die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter denn ohne dass wir es und
wie wäre es überhaupt gar nicht möglich
gewesen denn wir stehen ja vor nicht
ganz so einfachen Zeiten die
finanziellen Spielräume sind verdammt
eng und dann ist es für uns Haushälter
besonders schwer und wir gucken sehr
intensiv auf die einzelnen
Haushaltstitel und vor allen Dingen auch
Projekte und hinterfragen an der einen
oder anderen Stelle auch diese Projekte
und schauen ob sie ihre Ziele überhaupt
eingehalten haben und das bedeutet
dass wir auch verstärkt Fragen an das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium gestellt
haben und deshalb auch an dieser Stelle
ein herzliches Dankeschön an das Haus
und auch an Karl Lauterbach denn die
Fragen wurden zügig beantwortet und das
ist gut
der freundlich fragt bekommt gute
Antworten vielleicht sollten sie mal
daran arbeiten
und das hat dazu geführt dass es eben in
den
Haushaltsberatungen verdammt viele
Änderungsanträge für den Etat 2023 bis
Bundesgesundheitsministeriums gegeben
hat und wir haben wesentlich reduziert
und gleichzeitig viel Schwerpunkte
gestellt beziehungsweise gesetzt
insgesamt ist der Italien
Haushaltsverhandlungen auf 24,5
Milliarden Euro gestiegen es hat vor
allen Dingen mit den Leistungen des
Bundes an den Gesundheitsfonds für die
von der Pandemie verursachten
Belastungen und den Zuschüssen zur
impfstoffbeschaffung zu tun das sind
Kosten von knapp 2,4 Milliarden Euro
nach wie vor ein Schwerpunkt auch in
diesem Haushalt während der
fortschrittskoalition haben zudem in den
Bereichen Digitalisierung
Gesundheitsprävention und der
internationalen Gesundheit mehr Geld
eingesetzt und damit haben wir gerade
die Umsetzung zentraler Punkte die im
Koalitionsvertrag vorgesehen sind
angeschoben
die Mittel für die Digitalisierung
konnten wir erhöhen dadurch kann die
Versorgungsqualität verbessert
Arbeitsabläufe effizienter gestaltet und
Personal entlastet werden das was wir
jetzt in die Digitalisierung investieren
insbesondere in die Vorhabenplanung und
den strukturprozess wird nachgelagerte
Vorgänge entlasten und damit auch Kosten
sparen deshalb sind die 5 Millionen Euro
zur Förderung der digitalen
Transformation eine gute Investition in
die Zukunft eine weitere Million ist für
das Notaufnahme Register vorgesehen und
dann gibt es da ja noch das Thema
Konnektoren ein sehr spannendes Thema
Berichterstattung haben wir ja lesen
können dazu und mir ist es tatsächlich
ein Rätsel wie man Verträge abschließen
kann in denen steht dass ein
unabwendbarer Tausch von Konnektoren
notwendig ist und das ist für die
Zukunft finde ich nicht zielführend und
deshalb bin ich dankbar dass das Haus
eine lö mit Sicherheit
entwickeln wird das zukünftig
Datenschutz berücksichtigt und
gleichzeitig diesen Tausch nicht mehr
notwendig macht das ist gut für die
Natur für die Nachhaltigkeit und es
sinnvoll und ich weiß auch dass unser
Minister an diesen Verträgen nicht
beteiligt war ich könnte mir vorstellen
wer es war ich habe jetzt über das
Budget gesprochen
noch
einige reichte Digitalisierung mein
Kollege Matthias miese spricht ja nach
mir ich kann mir vorstellen dass er
darauf noch näher eingehen wird ein
weiteren Schwerpunkt haben wir in der
Prävention und der Aufklärung gerade im
Hinblick auf die Legalisierung von
Cannabis und deshalb haben wir die
Kürzungen rückgängig gemacht und den
Titel wieder auf das ursprüngliche
Niveau zurückgesetzt 13,2 Millionen Euro
das ist wichtig und ich finde jetzt
haben wir zum zweiten Mal sehr deutlich
signalisiert was der Parlaments Wille
ist und ich erwarte im Regierungsentwurf
2024 dass die dieser Titel mindestens
bei 13,2 Millionen liegt gerne höher
im Zusammenhang mit der gesundheitlichen
Aufklärung der Bevölkerung haben wir
außerdem den nationalen präventionsplan
mit 850.000 Euro unterlegt den Zuschuss
an den Verein Aktion psychisch Kranke
konnten wir 150.000 Euro erhöhen das ist
wichtig damit der Psychiatrie Dialog
fortgeführt wird der wichtige und
wertvolle Impulse zur Weiterentwicklung
des versorgungsangebotes gibt
schließlich
haben wir uns auch die Suizidprävention
angeschaut es gibt da definitiv Dinge
die man nutzen kann Synergien nutzen
kann wir haben das Haus damit einen
kleinen Hausaufgabe gegeben ich bin auf
den Bericht gespannt schließlich haben
wir ampelhaushälter im Bereich globale
Gesundheit Herr Braun hatte das ja
gerade auch schon einmal angeführt noch
mal deutliche Mittel Aufstockungen im
Vergleich zum Regierungsentwurf
durchgesetzt
3,75 Millionen Euro sollen als Zuschuss
eigentlich fließen und eine Millionen
eben noch mal an den global hell hat ja
wir wissen mehr ist immer besser aber
bei einem so engen Haushalt ist es
verdammt schwierig vielleicht haben wir
nächstes und über nächstes Jahr mehr
Möglichkeiten
insgesamt bleibt zu sagen dass wir im
Jahr 2023 große strukturelle
Herausforderungen im Gesundheits- und
Pflegesystem vor uns haben ich bin davon
überzeugt dass wir mit dem jetzigen
Haushalt eine solide Grundlage dafür
geschaffen haben die kommenden Ausgaben
zu meistern mit diesem Haushalt leisten
wir unseren Gesundheits politischen
Beitrag für den Zusammenhalt in der
Zeitenwende und daher können sie einfach
nur zustimmen ich tu's danke schön
vielen Dank
ja das ist der beruhigend dass die
Berichterstatterin der SPD dem Haushalt
zustimmen wird nächster Redner in der
Debatte ist der gesundheitspolitische
Sprecher der AFD Martin sichert
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
bettklägerige Senioren liegen
stundenlang hilflos in ihren eigenen
Fäkalien ein Verstorbener Licht tagelang
im Bett einen anderen Sterbenden
erreicht der Notarzt nicht weil er nicht
ins Haus kommt was wie Apokalypse klingt
ist diesen Monat in einem Seniorenheim
in Marburg Realität ein Pfleger sagt
dazu ich zitiere das Haus steht in
Flammen es geht nichts mehr keiner von
uns egal ob mit oder ohne Symptome in
Quarantäne darf mehr rein und sich um
die alten Menschen kümmern
gesunde Pflegekräfte dürfen wegen der
Politik dieser Bundesregierung nicht
arbeiten und müssen die Hochbetagten
Senioren völlig würdelos einsam in ihren
stinkenden Experimenten liegen lassen
Menschen verachtender als die Zustände
in diesem Heim ist nur noch die Politik
ihrer Bundesregierung
richtig sie haben keinen Respekt vor dem
Pflegekräften das sagen sie ganz richtig
sie rauben den Hochbetagten Senioren
ihren Angehörigen und auch den
Pflegekräften die würde schämen sie sich
ja Lauterbach schämen sie sich
für über 10.000 neue Stellen in Behörden
hat die Ampel Geld im Gesundheitswesen
hingegen bestraft man die dringend
benötigten Fachkräfte allein in Jena
bekommen diese Tage
654 ungeimpfte Mitarbeiter im
Gesundheitswesen Bußgeldbescheide über
jeweils 250 € Strafe und warum nur weil
sie die völlig unsinnige
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
eingeführt haben von der sie inzwischen
selbstabstand nehmen aber sie ist nun
mal noch in Kraft und richtet weiter
Schaden an obwohl wir von der AFD als
einziger von Anfang an davor gewarnt
haben die eine Zwischenfrage aus der
Fraktion DIE LINKE
Frage bitte schön
Herr Kollege sichert nehmen Sie zur
Kenntnis dass die Stadt Jena sämtliche
Bußgeldbescheide zurückgenommen wird und
dass diese nicht versendet werden sie
auf erzählen hier Unwahrheiten
die Stadt Jena hat vor zwei Tagen noch
in der Presse verkündet dass sie
entsprechend diese Bußgeldbescheide
raussenden wird und dass man diese Leute
so unfassbar in der Unsicherheit lässt
ob sie jetzt Bußgeldbescheide bekommen
oder ob sie keine Bußgeldbescheide
bekommen das Anfragen der Stadt Jena bei
der Landesregierung dazu geführt haben
dass die so und dort die Informationen
bekommen hat naja sie sollen doch ca ein
Zehntel des Möglichen Bußgelds von 2500
250 €, den Leuten geben und dass man
dann gesagt hat naja dann geben das den
Leuten halt dann vielleicht im März und
nicht jetzt Weihnachten sie führen mit
ihrer Politiker dieser Ampel Politik
Ampel führt mit ihrer Politik zu einem
absoluten Chaos und sie führt dazu dass
die Leute verunsichert sind und wir
haben viele Fälle bundesweit wo
tatsächlich Bußgelder auch verhängt
worden sind wo Leute bestraft worden
sind und zwar nicht nur im
Gesundheitswesen sondern auch bei der
Bundeswehr wo wir immer noch diese
ganzen Probleme haben hören Sie endlich
auf die ungeimpften Menschen in diesem
Land zu verlieren hören sie auf mit der
Diskriminierung
deutschland braucht nicht noch mehr
Bürokraten die aktenstapelwelsen sondern
deutschland braucht mehr Menschen die
bereit sind anzupacken die meisten von
uns werden irgendwann mal alt oder krank
sein und dann ist es völlig egal wie
viele Amtsschimmel Viren was dann zählt
ist die viele Pflegekräfte Ärzte und
andere Menschen in Heilberufen da sind
um uns zu helfen mein Vorschlag stampfen
sie tausend ihrer neuen Stellen ein und
bezahlen Sie damit alle Bußgelder der
von ihnen nun über zwei Jahren
drangsalierten ungeimpften Fachkräfte
und der ungeimpften Soldaten
19% Übersterblichkeit hatten wir allein
im Oktober auch in den Monaten davor gab
es deutliche Übersterblichkeit in einem
sind die Experten sich einig nämlich
dass diese Übersterblichkeit andere
Ursachen als Corona haben muss die
Bundesregierung unternimmt nichts um das
zu untersuchen und auch im Haushalt für
nächstes Jahr sind keine Gelder dafür
vorgesehen es könnten ja schließlich
unangenehme Ergebnisse dabei
herauskommen nicht wahr es ist zutiefst
beschämend Herr Lauterbach wie sie sich
vor ihrer Verantwortung wegduckend
200 Millionen für eine unnütze waren App
hunderte Millionen Werbung für nur an
Mäusen getestete Impfstoffe und aber
Milliarden für Masken und Impfstoffe
dafür Bargeld da und dafür ist Geld da
in der Gesundheitsversorgung hingegen
fehlt ist viele Arztpraxen und
Facharztpraxen stehen vor dem Aus wegen
Energiekosten Inflation und dem hohen
Alter der Ärzte dabei müssen viele
Patienten jetzt schon auf Ortstermine
viele Monate warten wie wird das erst in
Zukunft werden und noch schlimmer sieht
bei den Hebammen aus die sie absolut
stiefmütterlich behandeln um deinen
fehlen zehntausende Fachkräfte egal ob
Sie Herr Lauterbach oder ihr
Amtsvorgänger sparen viel zu lange wurde
Geld vor allem investiert um die
Ideologie der Regierenden und die
Interessen der Lobbyisten zu befriedigen
damit muss Schluss sein
nicht die Menschen müssen der Politik
dienen sondern die Politik muss endlich
wieder den Menschen dienen und weil
dieser Haushalt nicht den Menschen dient
sondern die Politikern und den
Lobbyisten lehnen wir Ihnen ab
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
der Bundestag debattiert über den
Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit mit
24,5 Milliarden Euro gibt es deutlich
weniger Geld als im vergangenen Jahr da
waren es noch 64,36 Milliarden die
Folgen der Pandemie in diesem Jahr muss
ich sagen mich im letzten mit 64,36 im
kommenden soll es dann 24,5 geben so ist
es richtig so und die nächste Rednerin
ist Paula schaut auf den grün nach
diesem negativ Beispiel vielen lieben
Dank Helge braun Sven Kinder hat am
Anfang der Woche gesagt dass man die
Union in der Opposition manchmal nicht
versteht gerade auch was
haushaltsklarheit und Wahrheit angeht
für den Einzelplan 15 muss man sagen wir
verstehen sie sehr gut und wir finden
das als sehr konstruktive Opposition die
sind in dem Bereich wahrnehmen und
deswegen an der Stelle groß und dann
kann sie aber auch natürlich an alle
meine mit berichter insbesondere auch
sehr Stadler und Carsten klein wir haben
uns ja heute auch aus Versehen farblich
abgesprochen so gut funktioniert die
Ampel im Einzelplan 15
ich habe in den letzten Wochen ich habe
in den letzten Wochen versucht die
Realität der Deckblätter während der
haushaltsverhandlung zum Einzelplan 15
mit der Realität vor Ort im
Gesundheitswesen in Einklang zu bringen
und immer wieder miteinander
abzugleichen ich war deswegen viel
unterwegs auch in den Kliniken meiner
Region sehr unterschiedliche Ostsachsen
Westsachsen kleine Häuser und große
Häuser teilweise in kirchlicher
teilweise im privater Trägerschaft und
man würde ja denken dass in dieser Zeit
wo ganz Deutschland übersteigende
Energiepreise und Inflation redet das
ist auch das dringendste Thema in den
Kliniken wäre aber das war tatsächlich
nicht so weil der Fachkräftemangel im
Gesundheitswesen so eklatant ist dass er
selbst aktuell die Frage der Inflationen
Energiepreise überstrahlt Kliniken die
teilweise inzwischen ihr Personal so
stark zentralisieren müssen
zusammenziehen müssen im op-trag damit
wenigstens der OP Betrieben läuft wo wir
früher Probleme hatten Patienten in die
anstoßbehandlung in die Pflege weiter zu
entlassen ist inzwischen nicht mal mehr
die Pflege das das Nadelöhr sondern der
Krankentransport der die Patientinnen
und Patienten abtran sein könnte in
einzelnen Kliniken meiner Region der
Fachkräftemangel ist das eklatanteste
Problem weiterhin im Gesundheitswesen
auch in diesem Jahr und da werden Ihnen
alle Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
auch bestätigen dass es nicht nur eine
Frage des Geldes und es wird vor allen
Dingen auch daran deutlich
dass wir ja in den letzten drei Jahren
erhebliche zusätzliche Gelder in die
Kliniken gesteckt haben wenn wir die
letzten drei Jahre zusammen nehmen mit
den krankenhausausgleichszahlungen den
intensivbettenförderung und den
versorgungszuschlägen
22,233 Milliarden on top für die
deutschen Kliniken und das wird auch da
wird auch so ein bisschen deutlich das
Ende des Lösungsansatzes mehr Geld für
strukturelle Probleme im
Gesundheitswesen wenn man sieht dass
trotz dieser 22 Milliarden kein einziges
Problem im Klinikbereich gelöst ist nach
diesen drei Jahren sondern wir jetzt
nach den letzten drei Jahren ins nächste
Jahr gehen und jetzt den härtefallfond
für die Kliniken auflegen noch mal bis
zu 10 Milliarden weil einfach
grundlegende strukturelle Probleme im
Klinikbereich nicht gelöst sind meine
Damen und Herren
dieser härtefallfond ist im Einzelplan
60 angesetzt und wir fanden es aber als
Berichterstatter im Gesundheitsbereich
unglaublich wichtig den mit einer
Maßgabe zu versehen denn dieser
Härtefall ist notwendig weil die Länder
in den letzten Jahren strukturell ihre
Kliniken unterfinanziert haben die
krankenhausinvestitionskosten
Finanzierung jedes Jahr geschätzt 4
Milliarden die die Länder dort nicht zur
Verfügung stellen und die deswegen nicht
vorhandene Gebäude Modernisierung die
deswegen nicht vorhandene
energieeffizienz ist ja eine
Voraussetzung dafür dass wir jetzt in
dieser aktuellen Situation der
notwendigen größeren Energieeffizienz
der hohen Energiepreise überhaupt als
Bund wieder die Lücken füllen müssen die
teilweise die Länder gerissen haben und
das ist keine nachhaltiger Lösungsansatz
und deswegen haben wir auch als
Haushaltsausschuss mit guter Mehrheit
dem der Bundesregierung jetzt mitgegeben
dass Sie sofort den Gesprächen mit den
Ländern eintreten muss um sofort
Programme aufzulegen zur energetischen
Sanierung denn wir müssen hier nicht nur
als Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestages
sondern dann auch als Patientinnen und
als Beschäftigte im Gesundheitswesen den
Ländern zutrauen was die Länder sich
selber nicht zutrauen nämlich ihre
eigenen Aufgaben endlich auch suffizient
wahrzunehmen meine Damen und Herren
denn zur Wahrheit gehört auch
denn zur Wahrheit gehört auch wenn wir
uns die gesamte Ausgaben
Gesundheitswesen anschauen zum Beispiel
wie sie dieses Jahr für 2020
veröffentlicht wurden knapp 441
Milliarden Euro die das Gesundheitswesen
in Deutschland dieses Jahr umsetzt das
ist fast so groß wie ein gesamter
Bundeshaushalt auch in diesen Zeiten und
das macht auch deutlich wie begrenzt an
der Stelle auch die Möglichkeiten eines
einzelnen Akteurs wie zum Beispiel des
Bundes sind der Bund kann nicht allein
mit Mitteln des Bundeshaushalts die
schwerwiegenden strukturellen Probleme
im Gesundheitswesen lösen wir können
auch hier nur Symptome Linderung machen
wir kommen an den grundlegenden
strukturellen Form auf allen Ebenen auch
mit den Ländern auch mit den Kommunen
und vor allen Dingen auch mit der
Selbstverwaltung Gesundheitswesen
einfach nicht vorbei sonst werden wir
jedes Jahr nur weiter Symptome Linderung
machen die sehr teuer ist und aber keine
Probleme grundlegend
jetzt lassen Sie mich noch kurz einzelne
kleine schlaglichte auf kleinere
Projekte werfen die wir auch im
Einzelplan 15 angesprochen haben Svenja
Stadler hat dankenswerterweise schon
einige genannt ich möchte noch die
longkowit Beratung ergänzen viele
Patientinnen und Patienten sind gerade
sehr stark davon beeindruckt wie viele
Informationen über longkow wird im
Umlauf sind die teilweise auch schwer
für Patientinnen und Patienten
überprüfbar sind hier stärken wir die
neutrale faktenbasierte Beratung für
eine Übergangszeit bis das
Gesundheitswesen das selber vollständig
auffangen kann wir stärken wie es wenn
ja Stahl richtigerweise gesagt hat Jonen
Aids und den global hf- wir stärken auch
den nationalen präventionsplan und ja
wir haben und das bin ich an der Stelle
bin ich auch der Union und der
Linkspartei sehr dankbar mit fast
einstimmiger Einstimmigkeit die
Kürzungen im Bereich Suchtberatung die
das Bundesgesundheitsministerium
unerklärlicherweise wieder reduziert
hatte vollständig zurückgenommen der
Haushaltsausschuss hat hier zwischen
Opposition und Koalition sehr klar
gemacht dass er das als eine extrem
wichtige und zentrale Aufgabe gerade
auch nach der Pandemie und gerade auch
in Zeiten der Cannabis Legalisierung
ansieht vielen vielen herzlichen Dank
auch an Helge braun und gesehene
Geld ist wichtig aber es ist nicht alles
das wird in jeder Mitarbeiter und jeder
Patient im Gesundheitswesen
bestätigen und ich freue mich dass wir
im nächsten Jahr in dieser guten
Konstruktivität die wir in den Beratung
des Einzelplans 15 haben uns auch daran
machen das Gesundheitswesen und die
Pflegeversicherung tatsächlich jetzt
endlich auf sehr viel stabilere Füße für
die kommenden Jahre zu stellen vielen
herzlichen Dank
war auch die Berichterstatterin für die
Bündnisgrünen für den Eisbahn 15
Gesundheit und Gesine Lötstelle
vertretender Fraktionsvorsitzende Linke
ist auch Berichterstatterin
für ihre Fraktion findet euch Gesundheit
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren Karl
Lauterbach
will knallharter Sanierer
trieb wir brauchen keinen Minister
Themen auf noch mehr profittrimmt wir
brauchen ein Gesundheitsminister der
dafür sorgt dass kranke Menschen
ordentlich versorgt werden meine Damen
und Herren
nun hat es der Sozialdemokrat Lauterbach
auf die Hebammen abgesehen die Hebammen
sollen nicht mehr von den Krankenkassen
finanziert werden sondern von den
Krankenhäusern den Krankenhäusern steht
aber das Wasser bis zum Hals sie sollen
in den kommenden zwei Jahren nur sechs
Milliarden Euro als Inflationsausgleich
erhalten Sie brauchen aber 15 Milliarden
um überleben zu können und nun sollen
diese Hebammen zwischen Krankenkassen
und Krankenhäusern zerrieben werden das
darf nicht geschehen meine Damen und
Herren eine Petition gegen diese
verwerfliche Idee wurde von 1,2
Millionen Menschen unterschrieben und
nun kam Herr Lauterbach zu der
erstaunlichen Erkenntnis der
wirtschaftliche Druck vertragen sich
nicht mit dem Berufsbild ich frage sie
verträgt sich wirtschaftlicher Druck mit
dem Berufsbild der Krankenschwester oder
der Ärztin nein sagen wir Gesundheit und
Profitmacherei müssen sich ausschließen
meine Damen und Herren
immer mehr Kinderärzte berichten mir
dass sie keine neuen Patienten mehr
aufnehmen können ein Arzt aus meinem
Wahlkreis in Berlin hat mir eine Grafik
geschickt sie zeigt eine steile Kurve
nicht gezahlter Honorare von 2009 bis
2022 er arbeitet trotzdem weiter weil er
Kinder und Eltern nicht nach Hause
schicken will mich rufen Mütter an die
Händlerin einen Kinderarzt suchen das
sind doch unhaltbare Zustände wir dürfen
unser Gesundheitssystem nicht weiter
kaputt sparen das wäre zutiefst in
normalen gemeinsam
und nun ist ja die missbotschaft und die
Mangelwirtschaft schon bei der
Medikamentenversorgung angekommen es ist
doch absurd dass in unserem Land
fieberhustensaft zur Mangelware wird
nehmen Sie Ihre Verantwortung dort war
Herr lauterbach
einfach die Schuldenbremse schlägt
erbarmungslos zu ganz anders als zum
Beispiel bei der Bundeswehr für die
scheint das nicht zu existieren sie von
der Koalition und auch von der Union
haben kein Problem im kommenden Jahr
insgesamt 72 Milliarden Euro für die
Aufrüstung der Bundeswehr auszugeben ich
frage sie sind neue Panzer Flugzeuge und
Granaten mehr wert als die Gesundheit
unserer Bevölkerung nein ich finde es
ist ein humaner Umgang mit kranken
Menschen ein Wert den wir verteidigen
müssen unser Gesundheitssystem darf
nicht kaputt gespart werden herzlichen
Dank
hat einen wichtigen Bereich angesprochen
tatsächlich der mangelnden Kinderärzten
auch der Mangel Ärzten auf dem Land das
ist weiter so und ist auch noch nicht
besser geworden das ist ein
Riesenproblem auch für den Bereich
Gesundheit in Deutschland Carsten klein
jetzt der Berichterstatter der FDP
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja zumindest das war natürlich in den
letzten Jahren massiv dominiert von den
Ausgaben für die Bekämpfung des
Coronavirus in 2021 haben wir 28,9
Milliarden Euro für die Bekämpfung für
Ausgaben 2022 in diesem Jahr
7,47,3 Milliarden Euro geplant und jetzt
für 2023 nach der Bereinigungssitzung
4,9 Milliarden Euro das sind Ausgaben
für die Ausgleichszahlungen in den
Krankenhäusern für die
Pflegeversicherung für die
Krankenversicherung für die persönliche
Schutzausrüstung Masken für impfen fürs
Testen und für Medikamente und diese
großen Zahlen zeigen zum einen das ist
natürlich richtig war in einer Krise mit
massiven Haushaltsmitteln gegen diese
Krise anzukämpfen aber sie zeigen auch
jetzt wo die Pandemie am Auslaufen ist
dass wir diese Haushaltsmittel auch
wieder ausschleifen lassen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen denn
krisenstrukturen dürfen nicht auf Dauer
finanziert werden und da ist die
Diskussion um die testverordnung in den
letzten Tagen wirklich nicht symbolisch
gewesen Herr Minister ich möchte mich an
der Stelle auch noch mal ausdrücklich
bei Ihnen und bei ihrem Haus bedanken
aber auch bei den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der koalitionsfraktion wir sind
uns nicht über einig welche Maßnahmen in
welcher Geschwindigkeit ausgeschrieben
werden sollen was zurückgefahren werden
muss am Ende erzielen wir immer gute
Kompromisse für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in diesem Land und nach einem
Zwischenschritt im Sommer wo wir ja
schon die anlasslosen die symptomfreien
Tests mit einer Zuzahlung belegt haben
fokussieren wir uns jetzt im nächsten
Schritt der Minister auf die bularablen
Gruppen in den Krankenhäusern in den
Pflegeheimen zu Hause das setzt den
richtigen Akzent in der jetzigen
Situation und ist der Lage angemessen
wenn alle offiziellen Statistiken egal
ob ich mit die inzidenzwerte anschaue
die Hospitalisierung oder auch die die
aufgrund von Corona auf Intensivstation
behandelt werden müssen gehen ja Gott
sei Dank alle zurück diese Zahlen dürfen
uns aber nicht davor abhalten auch die
Lehren aus dieser Krise zu ziehen und
ich glaube bei einer Lehre sind wir uns
in dem Haus alle einig außer einer
Fraktion nämlich wenn es darum geht dass
wir Pandemie nur gemeinsam international
bekämpfen können und deshalb ist es
richtig deshalb ist es richtig dass die
Koalition die Mittel für die
internationale Gesundheitsversorgung
noch mal um 4,75 Millionen Euro in der
Bereinigung Sitzung aufwachsen lassen
hat da auch noch mal ganz herzlichen
Dank an die Kolleginnen der
koalitionsfraktion liebes Svenja Liebe
Paula aber natürlich auch lieber Helga
an euch ich will aber trotzdem da auch
noch mal richtig stellen wenn man die
bei der internationalen
Gesundheitsversorgung
herausrechnet also die Mittel die in der
corona-krise wirken sollten vor allem
bei der internationalen Impfkampagne
dann sind die Mittel Aufwüchse im
Vergleich zum Beispiel zu 2020 geben wir
45 Millionen Euro mehr aus für die
internationale Gesundheitsversorgung in
2023 und deshalb glaube ich kann man von
einem
rückwärtsgewandten Schritt hier nicht
sprechen eine weitere Lehre muss
natürlich die Frage sein wie wir in
Zukunft wir die Aufgabenverteilung
zwischen Bund und Ländern richtig
justieren eigentlich ist es klar
geregelt Katastrophenschutz
Infektionsschutz ist Ländersache und
deshalb müssen die Länder jetzt die
Vorbereitungen treffen in der nächsten
Pandemie auch aus eigener Kraft
handlungsfähig zu sein da geht es um die
Digitalisierung des öffentlichen
Gesundheitsdienst die jetzt vom Bund
wieder mitfinanziert wird da geht es
natürlich um die Frage wer trifft denn
Vorsorge für personliche
Schutzausrüstungen in Zukunft alles
länderaufgaben und deshalb Minister
glaube ich neben den anderen Aufgaben
müssen wir auch hier in Gespräche
eintreten dass die Länder jetzt ihre
Aufgabenliste eigentlich erfüllen um in
der nächsten Pandemie dann auch
schlagkräftig zu sein
die Herausforderung im Gesundheitssystem
sind mannigfaltig Digitalisierung ist
ein großes Thema deshalb ist es auch
richtig dass wir gemeinsam in der
Koalition noch mal fünf Millionen Euro
für die digitale gesundheitsagentur in
der Bereinigungssitzung zur Verfügung
gestellt haben wir können enorme
Potenziale mit der Digitalisierung im
Gesundheitssystem heben das macht aber
auch erforderlich dass auch hier die
Länder mit sie nämlich wenn digitale
Infrastruktur in den Krankenhäusern
investiert werden muss das ist
Ländersache dafür gibt es einen
Bundestag zur anfinanzierung aber die
Länder müssen auch hier ihre
Verantwortung endlich gerecht werden
und dann ist es absolut richtig dass wir
als Koalition natürlich den
Krankenhäusern auch in dieser
Energiekrise helfen die Krankenhäuser
werden unter dem unter der Gas- und
strompreisbremse natürlich auch
subsumiert werden die werden daneben
noch den Härtefall vorbekommen alles das
was wir diese Woche ja haushalterisch
auch auf dem Weg bringen das heißt diese
Vorsorge ist getroffen jetzt muss das
natürlich noch gesetzgeberisch umgesetzt
werden aber das sind wir auf einem sehr
guten Zielgeraden und deshalb glaube ich
können sich die Krankenhäuser in dieser
Krise auf diese Koalition verlassen und
sie sollten sich in Zukunft auch auf die
Länder verlassen können damit sie
endlich ihren Investitionen abbauen
vielen Dank für Ihre aufmerksam
vielen Dank Herr Kollege klein
das Wort hat nun der Kollege Dinosaurier
cdu/csu-fraktion
die gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der
Union
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich finde das ja toll dass ich jetzt
hier auch die die Haushälter noch mal so
oben haben und sagen wie toll die
Haushaltsberatung waren aber das kann
natürlich nicht darüber hinweg täuschen
dass die
Haushaltsplanung so wie sie jetzt sind
und die Ampel im Grunde ein einziger
Widerspruch sind das kann ich Ihnen
nicht ersparen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und ich sage Ihnen auch warum
wir haben ja die Situation dass wir von
der pandemischen Lage in der endemische
Lage übergehen und da wäre es ja auch
Aufgabe gewesene der Koalition des
Ministers das entspricht dem Haushalt
auch abzubilden mein Kollege Helge Braun
hat er darauf hingewiesen wir haben die
völlig skurrile Situation dass wir auf
der einen Seite jetzt eine Impfkampagne
von 60 Millionen für das nächste Jahr
bekommen sollen obwohl überhaupt nicht
klar ist wie diese Impfkampagne beim
Bürger ankommen soll und insofern sage
ich Ihnen auch Herr Minister sie haben
auch der Kampagne ein berlin-dienst
erwiesen als sie gesagt haben das sein
alles schlechte Menschen und dann stellt
sich heraus dass es gecastete
Schauspieler waren also das sollten uns
so in der Form nicht antun und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gibt ja wie
gesagt durchaus gute Nachrichten also
die gute Nachricht ist dass die
pandemische Lage sich entspannt
glücklicherweise auch viele
panikprognosen des Ministers so nicht
eingetragen sind und insofern hätte ich
mir auch gewünscht hätten wir uns auch
als Unionsfraktion gewünscht dass in den
Haushaltsberatungen viele gute
Anregungen die wir gebracht haben auch
berücksichtigt worden werden und
insofern muss man sich doch auch
überlegen ist das sinnvoll 2,9
Milliarden in den Haushalt fürs nächste
Jahr einzustellen für Impfstoffe in dem
Wissen dass wir schon jetzt Millionen
von Dosen verwerfen werden müssen weil
wir leider auch diese Dosen nicht
verimpft bekommen wenn insofern hat das
mit haushaltswahrheit und Haushalts
Klarheit an der Stelle überhaupt nichts
zu tun liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Minister Lauterbach genau das ist
ja der große Widerspruch in ihrer
Haushaltspolitik einerseits reduzieren
sie Testangebote sie beenden Client die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht wo wir
als Union schon vor Monaten darauf
hingewiesen haben sich da klar zu
positionieren und nicht auf dem Rücken
der Pflegekräfte auszutragen wie diese
einrichtungsbezogen in Pflicht
letztendlich ausläuft sie wird zum
Jahresende auslaufen das ist gut aber
hätte schon viel früher passieren müssen
insgesamt muss man sagen läuft die
Debatte ein Haushalt unter Vorbehalt die
Ampel lässt alle großen Fragen zur
Finanzierung offen und ich sage Ihnen
auch warum GKV finanzstabilisierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenkassen da machen Sie
eine kleinere Form aber gehen nicht die
strukturellen Reform an im Bereich der
Krankenhäuser zeigen sie jetzt ja es
kommt eine Hilfe aber die größere Form
kommt erst im nächsten oder übernächsten
Jahr in der Pflegeversicherung tun sie
nichts bei der Frage Digitalisierung ist
alles auf Standby gesetzt also insofern
gehen sie endlich ins Handeln über das
ist ein Haushalt ich sagte genau wie die
Ampel voller Widersprüche das ist für
solides Haushalten viel viel zu wenig es
ist jetzt ein Jahr Regierungszeit vorbei
kommen sie endlich ins Handeln und es
umsetzen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Sorge
ja und die Vorwürfe der Opposition die
kann jetzt der zuständige Bundesminister
direkt beantworten Karl Lauterbach hat
jetzt das Wort
Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst einmal
diese Haushalt ist geprägt durch ein
Nebeneinander der Bewältigung von großen
Krisen Pandemie wo keine Krieg
Energiekrise Inflationsanstieg also
große Krisen und auf der anderen Seite
notwendigen Reformen und diese Reformen
sind immer unmittelbar notwendige
Reformen und Gestaltungen und alle
Bereiche gehen wir an gehen wir mit das
ist auch das was uns erwartet werden
kann wir gehen alle Bereiche an aber
bevor ich hier ausführe möchte ich mich
erst einmal ganz herzlich bedanken bei
allen die diesen Weg mitgehen wir
arbeiten ja derzeit mit sehr hoher
Taktung das geht für die Haushälter
vielen Dank an alle Fraktionen was die
Haushälter angeht ich bedanke mich bei
den Fraktionen bei den
Gesundheitspolitikern ich möchte mich
aber auch bedanken bei den vielen
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern im BMG
und den untergeordneten Institutionen
das Tempo ist derzeit hoch wir haben
viel vor uns aber ohne Mitarbeiters
miteinander diesen Teamgeist würde es
nicht funktionieren da man dank auch an
alle hier im Haus die konstruktiv
mitgearbeitet haben
ich komme
zunächst groß zur Pandemie zu sprechen
hier ist die gute Nachricht ja es ist so
wir haben hier Hinweise auf eine
Entschärfung der Situation das hängt
damit zusammen dass die Art und Weise
wie das Virus sich weiter also
verbreitet in einer Sackgasse zu geraten
scheint in dem eben nur noch geringe
Veränderungen möglich sind für das Virus
noch ansteckender zu werden somit gehen
diesbezüglich tatsächlich die
Nachrichten wissenschaftlich in die
richtige Richtung wenn es jetzt keine
sprunginnovation durch das Virus mehr
gibt dann sehen wir tatsächlich im
nächsten Jahr Möglichkeiten mit dem
Virus ganz anders umzugehen aber an der
gleichen Stelle möchte ich jetzt auch
sagen verlieren wir jetzt verlieren wir
jetzt bitte nicht die Geduld wir die
vernünftigen hier im Haus denn wenn wir
diese fair wenn wir diese wenn wir diese
Zeit noch
bewältigen wenn wir jetzt die Feiertage
ab werden wir die älteren Menschen und
die Vorerkrankungen jetzt absichern
werden wir noch einmal vorsichtig sind
dann können wir mit einer Bilanz durch
diese Pandemie gehen die besser ist als
die viele andere europäische Länder
daran haben alle hier mit beigetragen da
hat auch die
Opposition auch die Union mit
beigetragen daher bitte ich um ihre
Hilfe ihre Geduld wir haben hier noch
ein paar Monate wo ich schwerer sein
wird dann können wir anders damit
umgehen lassen Sie uns bitte jetzt nicht
im Stich und auch nicht diejenigen die
auf unsere Hilfe angewiesen sind
ich möchte es auch sagen also
beispielsweise die Aufhebung der
isolationspflicht das ist eine total
legitime Frage eine vollkommen legitime
Frage aber wir wollen bei der
isolationspflicht erst einmal bleiben
weil diejenigen die zur Arbeit gehen die
beispielsweise Risikofaktoren haben die
erkrankt sind krebskranke leukämiekranke
diejenigen die sich nicht gut durch
Impfung schützen können die verdienen
einen sicheren Arbeitsplatz das müssen
wir wahrnehmen die isolationspflicht ist
die Möglichkeit die wir haben und zu
verhindern dass der Einzelne nicht in
Angst sich am Arbeitsplatz aufhalten
muss
die Reformen die vor uns legen
betreffend vier Bereiche zum einen die
Finanzierung dabei haben wir große
finanzierungsreformen vor uns bei der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung aber
auch bei der Pflege große Defizite
mussten bereits beseitigt werden aber
wir machen eine große
Finanzierungsreform werden in der
Pflegeversicherung in zwei Schritten
vorgehen zunächst bis zum ersten siebten
den Beitragssatz stabilisieren dann
werden wir die Leistungen dynamisieren
und auch die eigenen Anteile in der
Pflege reduzieren wir werden darüber
hinaus in der kartenversicherung den
Steueranteil für Arbeitslosengeld 2
Empfänger und auch den Steuerzuschuss
erhöhen müssen so dass sie
Finanzstabilität der GKV gesichert ist
aber wir haben erst einmal hier eine
Reform gemacht womit wir Lage
stabilisiert haben wir machen jetzt die
Strukturreform das gleiche machen wir
auch im Krankenhaussektor im
Krankenhaussektor hat es unmittelbare
Handlungsbedarf gegeben wir brauchen
unmittelbar eine Lösung für die
Kinderkliniken Kinderkliniken waren von
der Insolvenz bedroht wir brauchen
unmittelbar eine situationsverbesserung
in der Geburtshilfe in der Geburtshilfe
die kleinen Geburtshilfe Kliniken kommen
nicht zurecht daher wird dort
unmittelbar reagiert wir brauchen eine
Lösung für die tagesstationäre
Versorgung weil oft übernachten die
Patienten im Krankenhaus nur weil der
Fall sonst nicht abgerechnet werden kann
es gibt keine medizinischen Gründe dafür
dass beseitigen wird und wir müssen
endlich einen neuen Sektor schaffen dass
die gleiche Leistung die im Ausland
längst ambulant erbracht werden kann
auch bei uns ambulant erbracht werden
kann so dass wir dort Pflegekräfte
entlasten diese Patienten werden in
Deutschland nur deshalb noch stationär
versorgt weil es sonst nicht gemacht
werden kann daher diese schnellen
Reformen und ein Pflege
entlassungsgesetz bringen wir auf den
Weg und an dem Tag nachdem wir diese
Gesetze beschlossen haben an dem Tag
nachdem wir diese Gesetze beschlossen
haben werden wir auch schon unser
Konzept für eine größere Form im
Krankenhaus vorstellen wo wir die
Überwindung der Fallpauschalen
vorstellen darauf warten wir seit 20
Jahren seit 20 Jahren wissen wir dass
das fahrpauschalengesetz zu einem
Hamsterrad Effekt in den Kliniken
geführt hat und wir werden jetzt nach 20
Jahren werden wir diese Reform für
durchführen somit wir arbeiten im hohen
Tempo und wir werden daher die
Krankenhausversorgung deutlich
entökonomisieren und dafür sorgen dass
endlich die medizinische Indikation des
medizinische Arbeit wieder voll im
Vordergrund steht und nicht mehr
ökonomischen Anreise
einen ähnlichen Stillstand und es wird
ja hier zu Recht darauf hingewerfen wir
müssen aber an ähnlichen Stillstand
haben wir auch bei der Digitalisierung
bei der Digitalisierung reden wir seit
ewiger Zeit über die Einführung der
elektronischen Patientenakte nee ist es
gekommen jetzt schaffen wir in einem
kurzfristigen Gesetz die dafür
notwendigen Voraussetzungen zum Beispiel
bei der Authentifizierung derjenigen die
dies nutzen wollen und dann schaffen wir
in einem großen digitalgesetz sofort
danach auch die strukturellen
Voraussetzungen dass sich die
elektronische Patientenakte befüllen
kann schauen wir uns doch an was
international alles möglich war durch
eine gut funktionierende elektronische
Patientenakte was wir nicht machen
konnten wir haben doch viele Dinge in
der Pandemie nicht machen können und
haben von ausländischen Daten
profitieren können die wir zum Glück
bekommen haben aus Israel wir wollen
demnächst so weit sein dass sich das
Deutschland auch für unsere
Informationen und Daten interessiert und
dass wir nicht die Bittsteller sind für
Daten in anderen Ländern weil wir die
elektronische Patientenakte nie auf den
Weg gebracht haben daran arbeitet die
aber wir reden nicht darüber Sorge wir
machen es und zwar mit höchster
Geschwindigkeit
zumindest erlauben sie zwei
Zwischenfragen aus den Fraktionen von
der Sorge cdcsu und aus der Fraktion DIE
LINKE ich würde die Zwischenfragen
zulassen werden
dinosäure CDU CSU vielen Dank Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister das Thema
Datennutzung will ich gar nicht weiter
adressieren weil wir hätten in der
letzten Legislatur die Möglichkeiten
gehabt beim forschungsdatenzentrum auch
Datennutzung besser zu ermöglichen nicht
nur für öffentliche Institution sondern
auch für private Unternehmen forschende
Gesundheitsunternehmen das ist leider an
ihrem Widerstand gescheitert das muss
ich jemals so klar sagen aber mich würde
eher interessieren sie haben jetzt
wieder viel angekündigt welche Reformen
geplant sind was kommen soll und deshalb
würde mich ganz konkret interessieren
wann kommt der Entwurf zur
krankenhausstrukturreform vielen Dank
vielen Dank für die Frage ich hoffe dass
wir in die die wichtig ich sag mal fünf
große Reformen im Krankenhaus die
Entlastung bei der also Energie Gaspreis
Strompreis indirekte Energiekosten
hoffen wir in der nächsten Woche
beschlossen zu haben in der nächsten
Woche hoffen wir zu beschließen das
Krankenhaus pflegen lassen zu setzen
dann als dritte Reform wir hoffen in der
wir werden in der nächsten Woche
beschließen die bessere Vergütung der
Kinderkliniken als förderreform wir
werden in der nächsten Woche beschließen
dass die Geburtshilfe besser bezahlt
wird als Fünfter Reform wir werden in
der nächsten Woche beschließen dass die
tagesstationäre Versorgung eingeführt
werden nächste Woche beschließen dass
sie über die kommen somit haben wir
sechs Reformen die kommen in der letzten
Legislaturperiode hat es keine einzige
gegeben nur zur Erinnerung und daher
glaube ich können wir gut darstellen und
werden unmittelbar unmittelbar nachdem
wir diese sechs Reformen gebracht haben
werden wir das große der
Expertenkommission Regierungskommission
Krankenhaus vorbereitete
drg-reformgesetz vorliegen wo wir die
DRGs dann überwinden werden somit werden
wir in sehr kurzer Zeit sehr intensiv
arbeiten das haben wir auch in den
letzten Wochen schon getan und ich muss
offen sagen wenn ich ganz direkt hier
sein kann das ist einfach was wir jetzt
machen sind zum Teil
aufholarbeiten von Reformen die über
Jahre hinweg liegen geblieben sind
so die weitere Frage aus der Personal
vielen vielen Dank dass Sie die Frage
zulassen ich bin auch über die
Ankündigung sehr gespannt die sie immer
wieder machen ich möchte auf eine Sache
Hinweisen dieses Jahr im Haushalt nicht
mehr vorhanden ist im letzten Jahr war
und würde ich sehr viele Pflegekräfte
wieder beschweren möchte die Frage mit
der Hoffnung verbinden dass sich an die
Kollegen Kollegen an die Pflege wenden
können um diesen flexit noch zu
verhindern da jetzt gerade wieder erneut
ansteht ich spreche von den eine
Milliarden der Kollege plantate hat
gleich 1000 Millionen genannt dass es
Pflege Bonus den Pflegekräften zur
Verfügung stand es kommt jetzt gerade
bei den Leuten an wie viele Menschen es
in der Pflege nicht bekommen werden wie
viele von diesen Pflege Bonus nicht
berücksichtigt werden das wird sagen
nach dem klatschen was zwei Jahre lang
um 9 Uhr immer anhielt sagen die
Leistung die auch ausgezahlt wurde an
den Pflegekräften das merken die
Menschen jetzt die sich noch in der
Pflege befinden was bei Ihnen alles
nicht ankommt und wer das ganze Geld
nicht erhält jetzt haben sie eine
erneute Ankündigung für eine Pflege
Entlastung nächstes nächste Woche die
von dem Finanzminister also unter
Vorbehalt der Finanzierung des finanzmin
das steht und ich möchte Sie bitten an
sich an die Pflegekräfte zu wenden mit
welchen Reformen sie den Menschen helfen
werden dass sie wirklich sich noch in
der Pflege befinden oder wieder zur
Pflege zurückkommen werden weil momentan
liegt nichts vor was diesen
Pflegekräften irgendwie in den flexit
irgendwie Einhalt gebieten wird vielen
vielen Dank
artiscopina
offen gesagt fällt es mir sehr schwer
diese Frage zu beantworten weil
offenbar folgen Sie dann die
Diskussionen nicht die wir seit Monaten
im Ausschuss haben aber schon ausgeführt
wir machen das Pflege das Kranken aus
pflegeentlastungsgesetz der Pflege
Bundes ist umgesetzt es gibt mehr als
3000 € in der Krankenpflege in der also
in der stationären Pflege und in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen sind die Mittel
ausgezahlt worden da hat es am Anfang
kurz zur Verzögerung gegeben darüber
haben wir berichtet dass die behoben
werden konnten somit sind die Pflege
wurden die ausgezahlt das
krankenhauspflege entlastungsgesetz
sieht darüber hinaus vor
bitte lassen Sie also wenn Sie eine
Frage stellen dann wäre es höflich wenn
sie nicht zwischen reden oder sonst
ja es macht keinen Unterschied also wenn
sie in der Fraktion so höflich wenn sie
in der Fraktion so höflich sein könnten
dass ich den dass ich ihrem Kollegen die
Frage beantworten kann wir haben
wirklich im krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz haben wir zahlreiche
Maßnahmen die Pflege unmittelbar lassen
will zum Beispiel die tagesstationär
Versorgung dann müssen wir zahlreiche
Nachtdienste nicht notwendig sein wenn
wir durch das Hybrid der die Gesetz dazu
führen dass diese vielen vielen
stationären Aufenthalte die wir nur
haben damit sie abgerechnet werden
können wenn nicht also ambulant gemacht
werden könnte dann wird das die Pflege
entlassen können wir werden also in der
Kinderkrankenpflege und auch in der
Geburtshilfe werden wir die Pflege
entlassen wir rechnen die Hebammen
komplett auf das pflegebudget an das
geht mir die Möglichkeit auch zu
berichtigen was sie falsch gesagt haben
verlöte also auch die Hebammen werden
nicht von den Krankenhäusern bezahlt
sondern wird von den Krankenkassen
bezahlte selbst der in ihrem Beitrag war
das was ich will nur sagen es geht hier
wirklich nicht und Polemik sondern es
geht darum dass wir die Gesetze die wir
durchaus kritisch diskutieren dass wir
sie auch wirkt dass uns die Mühe machen
die Gesetze wirklich auch zu verstehen
denn es gibt immer auch also sozusagen
in der Umsetzung Differenzen da lernt
man voneinander aber diese Frage zeigt
aus meiner Sicht ohne dass ich ihr
polemisch erscheinen möchte dass sie
sich nicht ausreichend mit dem Gesetz
beschäftigt haben
ich komme zu den digitalen Bereich so
wir werden im Bereich der
Digitalisierung somit die
Voraussetzungen für elektronische
Patienten wir werden Sie dann umsetzen
und wir brauchen da große Würfe wir
wollen wieder dort führen sein und
lassen sie mich zum Schluss auf einen
Bereich noch zu sprechen kommen der
ebenfalls in massiver Form
reformbedürftig ist wir müssen ein
Versorgungsgesetz machen für die
Menschen die in den Gesundheitssystemen
arbeiten und zwar in jedem Bereich wir
brauchen mehr Medizin Studierende wir
brauchen endlich die Umsetzung des
Masterplans 2020 wir brauchen eine
bessere Approbationsordnung wir brauchen
eine bessere Regelung der Ausbildung der
Psychotherapeuten wir brauchen eine
verbesserte Verteilung der
Psychotherapeuten so dass man auch dort
versorgt werden kann wo ist von den
Verhältnissen der prekär ist wir
brauchen mehr Pflegepersonal aus dem
Ausland aber nicht von dort wo das auch
gebraucht wird und wir brauchen eine
bessere Ausbildung in den Heilberufen
miteinander
akademisierten Ausbildungen und der
beruflichen Ausbildung auch das werden
wir alles angehen somit wir haben viel
vor uns ich darf mich bei allen bedanken
die bereit sind diesen Weg konstruktiv
mit uns zu gehen und kann nur sagen es
ist richtig zu verlangen dass wir
anpacken aber ich kann nur sagen in
diesem Bereich gilt die Ampel wirkt und
arbeitet
vielen Dank Herr Minister
Karl Lauterbach der
Bundesgesundheitsminister hat unter
anderem Zuschüsse zu Beschaffung von
Impfstoffen gegen COBIT von 3,2
Milliarden Euro für das kommende Jahr in
seinem Haushalt in diesem Jahr waren es
noch 7,9 Milliarden Euro und es gibt
nicht wenige in diesem Land die im
vorwerfen die Pandemie künstlich zu
verlängern der nächste Redner jetzt in
dieser Debatte kommt von der AFD
verstanden
noch mal mit einer Kurzintervention und
hat er nicht vorhin schon eine
Zwischenfrage gestellt und ja aber
Wolfgang Kubik lässt sie zu Intervention
auch auf Hybriden Wege zulassen also ja
ich möchte noch mal darauf eingehen weil
der Herr Minister ja jetzt gerade eben
auch auf die Frage meines Kollegen
attisch Göppinger aus Linksfraktion wie
das so getan hat bei der konkreten Frage
warum bekommt nicht jede Pflegefachkraft
diesen Pflege Bonus wieder mit vielen
Worten nichts gesagt hat der Minister er
hat überhaupt nicht beantwortet weil ich
kann Ihnen das nicht ersparen
Entschuldigung wir bekommen alle massiv
Briefe dass uns Pflegefachkräfte
anschreiben und fragen warum bekommen
auf bestimmten Station
Pflegefachkräfte die nebeneinander am
Bett Patienten gepflegt haben in der
corona-pandemie warum bekommt der eine
oder die eine die Bonus und die anderen
nicht und ich kann Ihnen sagen woran das
liegt weil sie nicht nachjustieren weil
sie nicht sagen jeder soll das bekommen
und ich will ihn mal ich will ihn mal
vorlesen weil immer so getan wird als
sei das nicht so und was Mitarbeiterin
dazu sagen die sagen ganz normal dass
dieser Bonus die Sonderzahlungen für
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die auf der
gleichen Station Arbeiten
unterschiedlich gewährt wird also einmal
wird er gewährt einmal gar nicht und der
Grund bleibe für sie völlig
undurchsichtig was hier abgeht ist ein
Skandal und ein tritt für alle
Mitarbeiter im Gesundheitswesen die in
den vergangenen zwei Jahren wirklich bis
auf die Knochen alles gegeben haben das
sagen pflege Fachkräfte Herr Minister
und jetzt würde mich wirklich
interessieren warum differenzieren sie
da wir haben schon vor Monaten hier in
diesem Hohen Haus den Antrag gestellt
den Pflege Bonus für alle
Pflegefachkräfte zu zahlen für
Rettungskräfte für Feuerwehrleute und
Sie können doch nicht sagen die
klatschen schön das ist ja angesprochen
worden und wenn es dann um die konkrete
Dankbarkeit geht die sie ja immer
vollmundig überall erklären dann
differenzieren sie zwischen
Pflegefachkräften was dazu führt dass
die Akzeptanz vor Ort überhaupt nicht
mehr Spaß und mittlerweile
Pflegefachkräfte sogar sagen es wäre
besser gewesen man hätte diesen
pflege-bonus überhaupt nicht ins Leben
gerufen anstatt diesen Ärger vor Ort zu
produzieren wo niemand mehr versteht
warum jemand den Bonus bekommt und
jemand anderes nicht
wenn man jetzt möchten sie darauf
reagieren
ja vielen Dank ich finde es immer wieder
schade muss offen sagen wenn wir hier
etwas tun was also vielen
berechtigterweise hilft die also
Pflegekräfte verdienen diese
Unterstützung nehmen sie auch an
bedanken sich und es sind die
Pflegekräfte am Bett ich finde es immer
wieder schade wenn wir Geld ausgeben
wenn wir versuchen zu helfen und dann
wird dann ohne dass man genau wird an
wenigen Einzelbeispielen die
möglicherweise dann sogar stimmen das
ist ganz anders aber ich würde auch an
Sie die bitte richten wenn ich auf ihre
Frage eingehen dass sie mir die
Möglichkeit dann geben zu bitte ich
überhaupt ans Haus gerichtet an die
demokratischen Parteien hier im Haus wir
sollten uns kein Beispiel an der AFD
nehmen sondern uns ausreden lassen die
wenigen Fälle die es gibt die vielen die
wenigen Fälle die es gibt da sind weg
wirklich Fälle dabei die berechtigt sind
es ist tatsächlich so es wird ja
umgesetzt von den Krankenhäusern es gibt
berechtigte Fälle wo jemand den
bundesverdient und bekommt nicht wir
gehen wirklich jedem einzelnen dieser
Fälle nach aber es ist nicht richtig
dann den Eindruck zu lecken als wenn die
gesamte Reform nicht funktionieren würde
und als wenn wir die Pflegekräfte nicht
würdig hier bedienen würde wir haben es
bei den Pflegekräften ehrlich bedankt
wir haben den Bonus so umgesetzt wie es
uns richtig zu sein denn wir haben uns
nicht bezüglich mit den pflegeverbänden
intensivst abgestimmt wenn es kleine
Lücke noch gibt ist das okay gehen wir
demnach aber der falsche Eindruck um
hier ein paar oppositions Malen zu
machen dass wir uns um die Pflegekräfte
nicht kümmern würden das ist nicht
redlich und er spricht auch nicht der
Haltung unserer Regierung
vielen Dank Herr Minister nächster
Kollege Wolfgang gieler afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident Kolleginnen
und Kollegen zwei einhalb Milliarden
Euro ungefähr so viel wie der gesamte
umweltetat umfasst hat die Koalition
alleine in den Haushaltsberatung noch
mal auf den gesundheitshaushalt
aufgeschlagen und alle größeren Posten
drehen sich wieder um einen alten
Bekannten um das Coronavirus
die meisten Länder dieser Welt behandeln
kobit 19 inzwischen ähnlich wie eine
Grippe aber in Deutschland gibt es
weiterhin schlimme Wellen nämlich
panikwellen die freilich dann von der
Wirklichkeit widerlegt werden
der größte Aufschlag trägt wieder einmal
die Überschrift Beschaffung von
Impfstoffen
nur verschoben aus 2022 warum werden
überflüssige Bestellungen nicht
verschoben nicht storniert statt
verschoben
hat Frau von der Leyen die Verträge mit
der Pharma-Lobby im Hinterzimmer so
schlecht verhandelt
dass die EU und auch Deutschland nicht
mehr herauskommen
die Hersteller haben sich schon dumm und
dusselig verdient Herr Minister
Lauterbach kümmern sie sich endlich ums
Gemeinwohl und sorgen Sie für eine
Lösung
stattdessen wird nun für zusätzliche 60
Millionen eine neue Impfkampagne
aufgelegt ich frage mich sehr ob ihr
medizinische Kriterien entscheidend
waren oder doch eher die Weiterführung
des Geschäftes mit der Angst
die Medien die an den neuen 60
Werbemillionen prächtig verdienen werden
auch kaum durch kritische
Berichterstattung auffallen
spätestens für die nächsten
Bundeshaushalt wird auch die geplante
krankenhausreform eine wichtige Rolle
spielen viele krankenhaushäuser behalten
Patienten über Nacht da um mehr zu
verdienen das muss geändert werden Herr
Minister sie haben das angesprochen
aber wenn durch eine neue Regelung
künftig das Gegenteil passiert also
Patienten nur aus finanziellen Gründen
über Nacht nach Hause geschickt werden
dann haben wir bei der Reform das Kind
mit dem Bade ausgeschüttet
der medizinische Sachverstand muss
entscheiden
genauso darf mein Kliniken nicht einfach
aus Geld Gründen schließen die
ländlichen Gegenden dürfen nicht von der
Versorgung abgehängt werden auch hier
muss der Sachverstand entscheiden
ob künftig der Sachverstand über
Lobby-Interessen siegt werden wir sehen
für die afd-strafaktion ist das der
Maßstab der gesundheitsetat 2023 hat
diesen Test jedenfalls nicht bestanden
deshalb lehnen wir ihn ab
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
[Applaus]
nächste Redner ist die Kollegin Maria
kleinschmain sind es 90
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier im Raum
liebe Damen und Herren ZuschauerInnen
hier bei der Debatte insgesamt scheint
mir nach dem Vorlauf noch mal wichtig
dass wir das ein bisschen einordnen was
hier im Gesundheitsbereich diskutiert
wird wir reden über einen
gesundheitshaushalt der quasi ergänzend
ist zudem was im Kern eigentlich über
Beitragsfinanzierung läuft und wenn man
sich mal die
Dimensionen klar macht dann reden wir
über ca 20 Milliarden Euro die hier im
Bundeshaushalt eingestellt werden wir
reden aber alleine nächstes Jahr über
300 Milliarden Ausgaben nur über die
gesetzliche Krankenversicherung noch mal
weitere 59 Milliarden Euro für die
soziale Pflegeversicherung das muss ich
jeder klarmachen und das zeigt
ordnungspolitisch auch dass der dieser
Teil aller Aufgaben die wir hier
bewältigen über die Beitragsfinanzierung
läuft und wir insofern wenn wir über den
Haushalt reden über ergänzende Mittel
reden das ist wichtig damit man weiß wer
ist eigentlich zuständig und das hilft
auch ein bisschen insgesamt die
Einordnung zu haben und wenn wir da
schauen dann haben wir
aus einer corona-zeit einen hohen
Bundeszuschuss geerbt gehabt 65
Milliarden Euro corona-bedingten zahlen
die sind aber zurückgefahren worden ganz
zurecht weil wir eben weniger massive
Auswirkungen haben parallel haben wir
aber eine neue Krise die nämlich mit den
inflationsbedingten und Energie
bedingten Kostensteigerungen zu tun
haben und wir haben die Krise das
sowieso die stationäre Versorgung nicht
adäquat finanziert war mit Lücken aus
den Ländern mit Lücken auch aus der
bundessicht wenn wir gerade die
pädiatrien angucken und wenn wir die
Geburtshilfen angucken oder die
Notfallversorgung und wir haben es mit
einem gravierenden Fachkräftemangel zu
tun und all diese Dinge sind nicht neu
sondern die sind bestehen schon lange
als Problem sie gehen hier jetzt endlich
an und das ist die Besonderheit und das
führt auch dazu dass wir nicht nur
Krisenbewältigung hier in diesem
Fachbereich haben und mit Leistung und
hoher Leistung aus dem
Gesundheitsministerium sondern dass wir
umfangreichste Strukturreform
vorbereiten und diese in Teilen ja auch
schon in Gesetzesverfahren münden das
ist das was hier geleistet worden ist
und ich finde man kann nach einem Jahr
Ampel sagen ja wir können durchaus stolz
sein da sind wirklich große und
gravierende Themen angegangen worden
und wir haben die wirklich gravierenden
Strukturreformen die Anliegen die
dringend sind die haben wir auf dem Weg
gebracht und das Herr Sorge als Sprecher
der Fraktion würde ich auch von ihnen
erwarten dass sie da Antworten liefern
dass sie uns Antworten liefern wie wir
denn die Finanzlücke in der GKV
schließen werden was wir tun werden für
die krankenhausreform was wir tun für
die Gesundheitsversorgung und der
Neuaufstellung zwischen
stationärer und ambulanter Versorgung
wenn sie da Antworten liefern dann sind
sie endlich in der Lage auch als
Opposition uns hier wirklich ein
konstruktiven Beitrag zu leisten bisher
sehe ich das nicht und ich bin ziemlich
stolz auf das was von Seiten der
Ampelkoalition in diesen einem Jahr auf
den Weg gebracht worden ist
vielen Dank Frau
Kolleginnen kleinen
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin Katrin
Vogler dazu die Linke
und Katrin froh dass die Sprecherin für
Gesundheitspolitik der Linksfraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Lauterbach
nach so viel Selbstbeweihräucherung kann
ich nur sagen in ihrem Haushalt gibt es
wenig Licht und viel Schatten und
deswegen werden wir ihn ablehnen gut ist
dass Sie unsere Forderung aufgegriffen
haben bei der Sucht und Drogenprävention
wenigstens nicht zu streichen aber wenn
die Ampel endlich Cannabis legalisiert
was wir schon lange fordern dann steigt
doch auf der Aufklärungsbedarf und das
ignorieren sie absolut unverantwortlich
ist es wiederum bei der Aufklärung über
sexuell übertragbare Krankheiten zu
kürzen dabei nehmen gerade jetzt bei
jüngeren Menschen die HIV Neuinfektionen
wieder zu und die affenbrocken haben
noch gezeigt wie wichtig Informationen
und Aufklärung ist so geht das nicht
und ich wundere mich ja dass für ihre
gute Idee der gesundheitskioske die
gerade in armen Stadtteilen Vorsorge und
Versorgung ganz nah zu den Menschen
bringen sollten gar nichts im Haushalt
steht sie wollen diese von den
Krankenkassen finanzieren lassen aber
das ist doch keine das ist doch eine
staatliche Aufgabe und die Kassen sind
doch eh am Limit und da prophe zeige ich
Ihnen so setzen Sie das ganze Projekt in
den Sand und schaden damit diesem
wichtigen Anliegen
und die Versicherten werden ja wegen
ihrer vermogsten kassenreform sowieso
schon kräftig zur Kasse gebeten und das
in Zeiten großer Teuerung im Haushalt
für 2023 findet sich da noch ein
besonders dämlicher Taschenspieler Trick
nämlich ein staatlicher zwangskredit an
die Krankenkassen wie soll der denn
eigentlich jemals wieder zurückgezahlt
werden also daher sage ich jetzt noch
eine Vorhersage wir werden uns im Herbst
nächsten Jahres hier wieder über
Beitragssteigerungen oder
Steuerzuschüsse unterhalten müssen weil
die Ampel sich auch in der
Krankenversicherung nicht traut hohe
Einkommen mindestens genauso stark zu
belasten wie niedrige wir brauchen eine
solidarische Gesundheits- und
Pflegeversicherung in die alle einzahlen
auch Abgeordnete Selbstständige und
Beamte und wir brauchen sie jetzt
vielen Dank
nächste Kollege Christine Lübcke
FDP-Fraktion und sie ist die Sprecherin
für sucht und Drogenpolitik weil
Cannabis schon öfter genannt wurde 12,2
Millionen Euro stehen in dem Bereich zur
Verfügung das sind aber weniger als im
Jahr 2022 herr Präsident werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr gerade
schon angeklungen als sucht und
drogenpolitische Sprecherin meiner
Fraktion bin auch ich erleichtert dass
wir diese Woche wieder ein Haushalt
verabschieden der rund 13,2 Millionen
für Aufklärungsmaßnahmen auf dem Gebiet
des Drogen und
suchtmittelmissbrauchsvorsieht und einen
Teil dieser Mittel haben wir für die
Präventionsmaßnahmen die wir im Rahmen
der Cannabis Legalisierung aufsetzen
werden vorgesehen
Prävention Prävention
jugendgesundheits- und Verbraucherschutz
sind nämlich die besten Argumente für
eine Legalisierung ich weiß einige hier
im Raum sehen das anders weil sie noch
immer Anhänger der gescheiterten
prohibitionspolitik sind aber sogar
US-Präsident Joe Biden hat diesen
Oktober angekündigt die Politik der USA
im Hinblick auf Cannabis zu reformieren
und warum eben weil auch er zu der
Überzeugung gelangt ist dass das der
bessere Weg ist
schauen wir nach Kanada da waren wir im
Übrigen mit dem Gesundheitsausschuss um
uns zum Thema Cannabis zu informieren
wir in der Ampel und gerade auch wir in
der FDP wir setzen nämlich auf Daten und
Fakten und nicht auf überholte
Stammtischparolen
welche Daten und Fakten die mitgereisten
Kollegen der Opposition da gehört haben
das weiß ich nicht aber bei der CSU
zumindest scheint noch nicht angekommen
zu sein dass in Kanada nicht der
Untergang des Abendlandes droht
und Aussagen von Markus Söder man solle
lieber beim da zitiere ich mit Erlaubnis
des Präsidenten bayerischen weiß wir
bleiben dass er in jeder Beziehung
besser und gesünder die sind nicht nur
faktisch falsch sondern reiner
Populismus
und unser bayerischer
Gesundheitsminister der hat anscheinend
auch nichts Wichtigeres zu tun als nach
Brüssel zu reisen um unser Land vor dem
Untergang durch die Cannabis
Legalisierung zu retten
meine Damen und Herren das zeugt von
keinerlei Sachkenntnis sondern vor allem
von dem absoluten Unwillen sich auch nur
minimal mit den Fakten
auseinanderzusetzen
denn auch der immer wieder von der Union
bemühte vergleichen mit den Niederlanden
der hängt unser Nachbarland hat Cannabis
eben nur entkriminalisiert und nicht
legalisiert und genau so wollen wir es
ja nicht machen
und deswegen
deswegen verweisen wir auch das Beispiel
Kanada dort wurde Cannabis 2018
legalisiert die Zahl der Nutzer hat sich
nach der Legalisierung stabilisiert
gerade auch bei den Jugendlichen vorher
als es verboten war sind die Zahlen
regelmäßig angestiegen das heißt die
Legalisierung hat viele Vorteile
insbesondere für den Jugend den
Gesundheits- und den Verbraucherschutz
und diese Überzeugungen spielen sich
auch im Haushalt für 2023 wieder
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
was ist das Wort natürlich
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir als
Fachleute wissen alle dass sich die
großen Finanzmittel Flüsse im
Gesundheitsbereich im Gesundheitsfonds
abwickeln und nicht im Bundeshaushalt
nichtsdestotrotz ist aber der
Bundeshaushalt für Gesundheit Einzelplan
15 mit in diesem Jahr 24 Milliarden
gegenüber dem Gesamtvolumen des Hauses
von ca 450 Milliarden alles andere als
bedeutungslos selbst unter
Berücksichtigung der Tatsache dass er in
diesem Jahr um 42 Milliarden abgesunken
ist wir müssen aber in diesem Jahr
bedauerlicherweise feststellen dass
unter dem Gesichtspunkt der
strategischen und strukturell
bedeutenden Ausgaben erhebliche
Fehlsteuerungen geleistet worden sind
seit der corona-pandemie wissen wir sehr
genau dass ich Gesundheitsgefahren und
die Lösung von Gesundheitsgefahren sehr
wohl global darstellen können und auch
nur mit diesem Arbeitstitel angegangen
werden werden müssen und deshalb enthält
der Einzelplan 15 auch vollkommen zu
Recht den Abschnitt internationales
Gesundheitswesen aber das ist ein ganz
trauriges Kapitel in diesem Jahr denn
wir haben wie schon von Kollegen Helge
braun beschrieben eine Reduktion von 70
Prozent oder in realen Zahlen von etwa
450 Millionen Euro auf nur noch knapp
146 Millionen 81 für die öffentliche
internationale Gesundheit 30 Millionen
für den neu errichteten who hab hier in
Berlin und
28,3 Millionen für die WHO in Genf das
sind eindeutig hier aus dem Haus die
falschen Botschaften eins muss man noch
mal ganz klipp und klar erwähnen wenn
man nicht müde wird wie sie fährt der
Minister das dauernde Lied der Pandemie
zu singen dann kann ich hier und heute
nicht wie im Haushalt L da erklärt aus
der Verantwortung bei ACTA der Kampagne
gegen Corona aussteigen wir müssen auf
internationale
Gesundheitsgefahren gerichtet sein wir
müssen die Fragen lösen wir müssen das
Management unterhalten wir müssen
internationale Gesundheitsvorschriften
ständig aktualisieren wir brauchen
Prävention für übertragbare Krankheiten
und wir brauchen Bekämpfung und
Strategien für übertragbare Krankheiten
weltweit
leistungsfähige Gesundheitssysteme und
Diagnostik sind die Grundlage für einen
umfassenden internationalen
Gesundheitsschutz und im Oktober haben
wir hier bei der bedeutenden
Veranstaltung des World Health Summit
sehen können mit welchem Renommee
Deutschland in der Welt in der
Zwischenzeit wahrgenommen wird und mit
welchem guten Ruf wir uns an der
Diskussion mit und für die Währung
beteiligen können auch für diese
Veranstaltung finden wir nur 500.000
Euro im Haushalt fährt der Minister
reden Sie bitte nicht immer nur über
internationale Studien sondern stärken
sie im Haushalt das Internet die
internationale Gesundheitsarbeit im
Interesse des deutschen
Gesundheitssystems so ist der Haushalt
jedenfalls nicht zustimmungsfähig vielen
Dank
vielen Dank Georg kippels für die CDU
auch keine so große Überraschung dass
die Union in Haushalt ablesen ablehnen
wird aus dem Gesundheitsausschuss kommt
jetzt hierher ein Engelhardt für die SPD
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Schülerinnen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger hier auf den
Tribünen
an den Bildschirmen und ganz besonders
aus meinem Wahlkreis Ravensburg und aus
dem Bodenseekreis
anders als unseren Kolleginnen aus dem
Haushaltsausschuss bleibt uns
fachpolitiker:innen die sehr sehr lange
Bereinigungssitzung erspart und auch
wenn ich gleich zum lobenden Teil meiner
Rede komme im Sinne des Arbeitsschutzes
muss ich sie hier wirklich erahnen
niemand niemand sollte 18 Stunden am
Stück arbeiten
ich drücke ihnen die Daumen das in
Zukunft solche Sitzungen wieder kürzer
werden
jetzt zum Haushalt der Minister und
unsere Haushälterin Svenja Stadler haben
sehr eben schon erwähnt wir können in
diesem Jahr trotz knapper Mittel einen
sehr guten gesundheitshaushalt
verabschieden
während der corona-pandemie haben wir
aber auch an vielen Stellen die
Finanzierung grundlegender Bestandteile
unseres Gesundheitswesens notdürftig mit
viel Geld sichergestellt
die Defizite die unter einem
Gesundheitsminister Spahn entstanden
sind wurden jetzt werden jetzt erst
richtig deutlich und die einzigen die in
der letzten Legislatur ausreichend
finanziert wurden und jetzt vor lauter
Geld noch kaum laufen können das sind
doch die Freunde und Bekannten des Ex
Ministers aus Münster und die
provisionsgemisteten Abgeordneten von
CDU und CSU
sollen wir
bleiben bei dieser Debatte jetzt als
eine Art Schuld Eingeständnis werden
[Musik]
hier sind Worte gefallen wie
kaputtsparen panikminister und
unanständige Bezeichnungen für einen
Minister und sein Ministerium die über
ihre Belastungsgrenze gehen ich bin froh
dass unser Gesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach ist und dass er vernünftig
und vorausschauend und umfassend
aber zurück zum Haushalt was haben wir
als
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion mit den knappen
Mitten erreichen können wir haben die
Mittel für die Drogenprävention
gegenüber dem Regierungsentwurf um 5
Millionen steigern können und weil hier
immer einiges vermischt wird die
Legalisierung von Cannabis macht mir in
dieser Hinsicht nicht so viel Sorgen wie
zum Beispiel der legale Konsum von Tabak
Alkohol und Schmerzmitteln besonders die
Folgen von Alkoholabhängigkeit habe ich
in meiner Tätigkeit an Zentrum für
Psychiatrie südwürttemberg immer wieder
erleben müssen
bundesweit leben schätzungsweise
zweieinhalb Millionen Kinder mit
Alkoholkranken Eltern zusammen im Umgang
mit Suchtmitteln müssen wir in unsere
Gesellschaft besser werden
über die Frauengesundheit habe ich an
dieser Stelle bereits gesprochen fünf
Millionen für die Erforschung der
Endometriose sind ein guter Anfang
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit und Teilhabe
bedingen aber auch weitere Forschungen
beispielsweise bei der Erprobung von
Arzneimitteln bei der Kindergesundheit
verweise ich sehr gerne auf meine
kolleginese hat baradari dank ihres
Einsatzes werden wir vom kommenden Jahr
an endlich die Arzneimittelsicherheit
bei Kindern und Jugendlichen verbessern
und auch angeborene Hauterkrankungen
besser erforschen
meine Kolleginnen Matthias Mewes und
Tina Rudolph werden gleich noch auf die
Verbesserungen in der Digitalisierung
des Gesundheitswesens und der globalen
Gesundheit eingehen so viel vorab wir
haben einiges erreicht und wir haben
noch viel vor vielen Dank
vielen Dank
nächster Redner ist der Kollege Ziegler
AFD
[Applaus]
herr Präsident sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
Herr Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach
schön sie mal wieder in live und in
Farbe zu sehen das war im
Gesundheitsausschuss doch eher in dem
überschaubarer Größenordnung und um das
jetzt mal deutlich zu sagen das war im
kleinen einstelligen Bereich und das bei
über 45 Sitzungen aber ich verstehe das
natürlich auch im Gesundheitsausschuss
keine Kameras im günstigsten Fall so um
die 50 Zuschauer und dann auch noch die
nervigen Fragen vor Opposition
beantworten das sind natürlich die
Auftritte von Millionen von Zuschauern
bei Illner Maischberger und Co 4
spektakuläre für einen so
leidenschaftlichen Selbstdarsteller
eine ihrer ersten Amtshandlungen hier im
Haus war das durchpeitschen der
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht für
die Gesundheitsberufe das war nicht nur
eine Nötigung sondern auch ein massiver
Angriff auf die körperliche
Selbstbestimmung und Unversehrtheit
aller Betroffenen die sich unter der
Androhung von Berufsverbot und damit
einhergehend dem Verlust ihrer Existenz
mit einem nur bedingt zugelassenen
Medikament behandeln lassen mussten
diesem Akt startet der Übergriffigkeit
hat am 10 Dezember letzten Jahres nur
die afd-fraktion die rote Karte gezeigt
und ja meine Damen und Herren ich kann
es ihnen nicht ersparen alle anderen
Fraktionen haben bei diesem Wahnsinn
mitgemacht
die eine kriegst du bezogene Impfpflicht
lassen sie jetzt übrigens heimlich still
und leise zum ersten des Jahres
auslaufen falsch quasi vom allerersten
Tag an bei dieser sogenannte Impfung
zwar sehr zuverlässig alle möglichen
schweren Nebenwirkungen auslöst aber
eine Übertragung von Coronaviren nicht
verhindert
Herr Minister wie wäre es denn mal mit
einer vom Bund angestoßenen Bildungs-
und studienoffensive in die Länder
hinein um endlich die Fachkräfte
Problematik in die Gesundheitsberufen zu
beheben fehlanzeiger sie nerven und
stattdessen und das auf allen Kanälen
mit einer millionenschweren ich schütze
mich im Promotion und nein es sind nicht
die nötigen Finanzhilfen
der durch die Energiepreise vor der
insolvenzbetroffenen Krankenhäuser an
der sie mit großer Leidenschaft arbeiten
sondern
gesundheitskirche oder die scheinbar so
dringende Freigabe von Cannabis
ehrlich gesagt es ist beängstigend wo
sie ihre Prioritäten setzen sehr
geehrter Herr Lauterbach wenn man sich
ihren Twitter-Account zu Gemüte führt
dann wird eins sofort deutlich ihre Fans
sind verschwunden der Wind weht dort
eisig ins Gesicht und das liegt nicht am
Wetter am 6 dezember werden sie 12
Monate im Amt tun sie den Menschen da
draußen und vor allem den Millionen
Mitarbeitern in den Gesundheitsberufen
einen Gefallen und machen sie das Jahr
nicht voll und treten zurück vielleicht
findet sich ein Nachfolger der dieses
Amt nicht zur Panikmache und
Selbstverständnis braucht sondern
endlich wieder verantwortungsvolle
Gesundheitspolitik für unsere Bürger
macht vielen Dank
der Bundestag debattiert über den
Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit in Plan von KL
Lauterbach der gerade zum Rücktritt
aufgefordert wurde freundlicherweise und
Karl Lauterbach hat diesmal 24,5
Milliarden für das Jahr 23 zur Verfügung
im vergangenen Jahr waren es noch 64,36
Milliarden der Unterschied ist
vor allem in die pandemiebekämpfung mit
30,3 Milliarden da bleiben nur noch 1,2
übrig der nächste Redner Armin drauf für
die gründermaßnahmen deutlich reduzierte
gesundheitshaushalten nicht
missverstanden werden darf Corona ist
angesichts von über zum Teil über 1000
Toten pro Wochen pro Woche in den
letzten Wochen nicht vorbei und es war
gibt keinen Grund unsere
Vorsichtsmaßnahmen vor den kommenden
Winter bereits völlig fallen zu lassen
wichtig ist in diesem Zusammenhang auch
die Mittel für die Forschung und
Beratung in Sachen longkowitz das ist
ein guter Anfang leider werden wir für
dieses bislang unzureichend erforschte
Thema Zukunft noch deutlich mehr Gelder
brauchen 70 Prozent der deutschen
Krankenhäuser rechnen 2023 mit roten
Zahlen das ist bedingt durch die
Inflation und massive Energiepreise
Steigerungen bei gleichzeitig fixen
Preisen auf der einen Seite und
verminderte Einnahmen bei
Fachkräftemangel und fallzahlrückgängen
auf der anderen Seite es ist sehr
wichtig dass wir hier jetzt mit 8
Milliarden aus dem Wirtschaft
Stabilisierungsfonds den
Gesundheitseinrichtungen tatkräftig
unter die Arme greifen für die
Beschäftigten und für die Patientin ist
dieser Beitrag in den nächsten beiden
Jahren wirklich wichtige Botschaft auch
wenn die Opposition verzweifelt zu
streuen versucht wir bereiten jetzt als
Ampel eine umfassende Reform der
Krankenhausfinanzierung vor etwas was
die Vorgängerregierung komplett verpasst
hat das aktuell fast ausschließlich auf
Fallpauschalen beruhigt System hat zu
schlechten Arbeitsbedingungen zu
ökonomischen Fehlanreizen in den
Kliniken geführt es hat ausgedient und
muss ersetzt werden
über fünf Prozent der klimaschädlichen
Emissionen kommen in Deutschland zum
Gesundheitswesen der größte Teil davon
aus dem Krankenhäusern dort sind
dringend mehr Investitionen in
Energieeffizienz erforderlich das ist
völlig richtig dass die Haushälterin
hier ein Sonderprogramm für die
energetische Sanierung der Krankenhäuser
fordern das sind zweifelsohne die Länder
jetzt in der Pflicht den Klima ist es am
Ende egal woher die Mittel kommen die zu
seinem Schutz beitragen aber handeln
müssen wir jetzt ganz dringend und ich
bin überzeugt dass wir dann am Ende
einigen können und auf einen guten Weg
sind
Annen grau ist selber Arzt und er hat
hier noch mal darauf hingewiesen dass es
immerhin noch tausend Tote pro Woche
gibt also Corona von vielen Weg
gewünscht ist immer noch da Diana
Stücker jetzt für die CDU CSU sie ist
Mitglied im Gesundheitsausschuss
ein Haushalt aufzustellen ist nie
einfach es geht lange Wunschlisten aller
Bundesministerien zu berücksichtigen und
zu verhandeln ein Haushalt darf sich
jedoch nie nur ausschließlich an dem
Wunschkonzert eines Koalitionsvertrages
orientieren es gibt auch
außerordentliche Aufträge für neue
gesetzliche Regelungen zum Beispiel vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht ein solcher
Auftrag ist dem begleiteten Suizid neu
zu regeln wir befinden uns als
Abgeordnete inmitten einer sehr ernsten
komplexen und ethisch schwierigen
Debatte es liegen drei sehr
unterschiedliche Gesetzesvorschläge vor
und die Entscheidung wird im Frühjahr
kommenden Jahres anstehen das
verbindende Element dabei aber ist dass
sich alle für den Ausbau und die
Stärkung von
Suizidprävention sowie von Hospiz und
palliativ Angeboten aussprechen die
Erfahrung zeigt das bei sehr vielen
Menschen mit suizidalen Gedanken hinter
diesem Ansinnen ein Hilferuf nach einem
erträglichen und menschenwürdigen Leben
steht im Rahmen der Suizidprävention
muss es deshalb oberstes Ziel sein mit
den Menschen die einen Suizid in
Erwägung ziehen in Beziehung zu treten
und gemeinsam
die hinter dem Wunsch zu sterben
verborgene Aussichtslosigkeit zu
begreifen damit auch andere Wege in
dieser Krise denkbar werden können und
dazu gehört die psychologische
psychotherapeutische und psychiatische
Regelversorgung zu verbessern sowie
spezifische Regelungen zur Verbesserung
der allgemeinen Suizidprävention
voranzutreiben dazu gehört zeitnah der
flächendeckende Ausbau der Anzahl der
kassensitzen niedergelassener
psychologischer und medizinischer
PsychotherapeutInnen und psychiaterinnen
um eine schnelle und dauerhafte
Versorgung von Menschen mit psychischen
Erkrankungen gewährleisten zu können
bereits heute ist die Versorgung nicht
ausreichend dazu gehört psychiatrische
und psychotherapeutische
kriseninterventionsangebote für Menschen
in einer akuten psychischen Notlage
auszubauen flächendeckend und 24 Stunden
7 Tage die Woche in Netzwerk mit
bestehenden Diensten und Einrichtungen
auch die weitere Verbesserung der
hospiz- und Palliativversorgung für
schwerstkranke Menschen ist anzugehen
dazu gehört die Palliativversorgung in
vollstationären Pflegeeinrichtungen und
Hospizen zu stärken dazu gehört
psychosoziale Fachkräfte regelhaft in
die spezialisierte ambulante
Palliativversorgung zu integrieren und
dazu gehört gezielte
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit zu Hospiz
palliativer Beratung Begleitung und
Versorgung
alle oben genannten Punkte müssen
finanziell hinreichend im Haushalt
abgesichert sein im Haushalt 2023 findet
sich davon nichts liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sie fordern zwar das
Gesundheitsministerium auf eine
nationale
suizidpräventionstrategie vorzulegen und
zwar innerhalb des nationalen
präventionsplans der Plan soll aber erst
bis April 2024 vorliegen bis zur
Umsetzung wird wichtige Zeit
verstreichen obwohl bereits jetzt klar
ist was zu tun ist jeder Gesetzesentwurf
muss bis zur Umsetzung zu Ende gedacht
werden stellen sie im Haushalt
ausreichend Mittel ein für das was
sicher kommt und notwendig ist und
arbeiten Sie nicht nur Ihre Wunschlisten
ab
vielen Dank Frau Kollege in Stuttgart
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren Haushaltsdebatten sind immer
Zeiten der Haushälter die sich dann hier
sehr konkret mit gesundheitspolitischen
Inhalten beschäftigen der Kernhaushalt
des BMG ist jetzt nicht wirklich das
Spannende an der Gesundheitspolitik das
wissen wir alle das spannende sind die
Dinge die direkt oder indirekt
dranhängen und da geht's dann meistens
bei den Voraussetzungen wie dort
Leistungen erbracht werden oder eben
auch Strukturen gebaut werden um dann
die Themen die wir uns zu kümmern haben
ich möchte aber doch eine Zahl aus dem
Kernhaushalt die 60 Millionen die sie
liebe Kollegen von der AFD hier gerade
angesprochen haben was die Impfkampagne
angeht aufnehmen um noch mal hier ganz
deutlich festzuhalten wenn Sie sich
anschauen dass wir zum Beginn des Jahres
2021 in Deutschland angefangen haben zu
impfen dann hatten wir am Ende des
Jahres 21 völlig Vernunft geleitet von
der Bevölkerung in diesem Land 75% der
Menschen die mindestens einmal und fast
ebenso viele die zweimal geimpft waren
dafür braucht es Entschuldigung Herr
Kollege Lauterbach kann Lauterbach als
Minister noch nicht mal dabei Jens Spahn
Minister und daran kann man ablesen dass
wir alle miteinander sehr vernünftige
Regeln in diesem Haus gefunden haben wie
man mit dieser Pandemie umgeht und wenn
wir bei Ihnen von der Union sind Herr
Kollege braun dann bin ich bei den
Verträgen die sie wollen angesprochen
haben zur Beschaffung von Impfstoffen
natürlich hat Jens Spahn diese Verträge
geschlossen und wir müssen heute gucken
dass wir diese Flexibilisierung die sie
dort einfordern in die Verträge bekommen
und wenn sie jetzt vermuten dass sich
diese 16 Jahre Nummer wieder anfange die
sie permanent beklagen dann ist das
nicht an dem ich will an der Stelle sehr
deutlich sagen die Gesundheitspolitik
der Union war eine unter großer
Unsicherheit die uns im Großen und
Ganzen sicher durch diese Pandemie
gebracht hat und der Kollege Lauterbach
setzt das jetzt fort und im Übrigen auf
der Grundlage eines Haushalts der uns
eine Rückkehr zur Normalität in diesem
Land erlaubt und wenn wir zu dieser
Normalität zurückkehren ich weiß nicht
was dazu lachen gibt
wenn wir zu dieser Normalität
zurückkehren dann gibt uns das den
Spielraum und die Zeit uns mit den
Fragen zu beschäftigen die heute auch
mehrfach angeklungen sind nämlich die
strukturellen Reformen die Bitte
notwendig sind in diesem Land und wenn
wir diese strukturellen Reformen im
Gesundheitssystem in Deutschland machen
dann wird es darum gehen dass wir und
ich will ein Beispiel ausgreifen weil
dann meine Redezeit auch zu Ende ist zum
Beispiel die pharmazeutische Industrie
die in diesem Land wieder auf dem Weg
ist Deutschland zur Apotheke der Welt zu
machen unterstützen und
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen dass wir
weiterhin in diesem Land einen
leistungsfähige pharmazeutische
Industrie haben die das möglich macht
was wir alle für die Patientinnen und
Patienten wollen nämlich innovative
Arzneimittel als erstes in Deutschland
auf den Markt zu bringen und nicht
woanders in Europa weil das sind die
Dinge die wir brauchen das
Paradebeispiel für das was ich gerade
sage ist die Stadt Mainz und die Firma
biontech und daran kann jeder für sich
ablesen welchen Weg die FDP in dieser
Koalition gehen wird und bestärkt wird
herzlichen Dank für Ihre aufmerksam
[Applaus]
der nächste Redner hier in der Debatte
über den Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit kommt
von der cdu/csu Dietrich mondstadt er
ist mit dem Gesundheitsausschuss
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Werte Damen
meine Herren bereits in der ersten
Lesung haben wir auch viele Missstände
und nicht aufgegriffene Fragen dieses
Haushaltsentwurf des Einzelplans 15
hingewiesen dies ist offensichtlich
nicht ohne Wirkung geblieben der
gesundheitsetat steigt knapp steigt und
knapp 2,5 Milliarden Euro an ebenso
werden immerhin knapp 2,5 Milliarden
Euro
knapp 1,2 Milliarden Euro des Bundes an
die Gesundheitsfonds für Belastung
aufgrund der corona-pandemie gezahlt
meine Damen und Herren aber das ist
leider nur ein Teil der Wahrheit
wichtige Bereiche die wir immer wieder
angemahnt haben bilden sich im Haushalt
nach wie vor nicht ab
meine Damen und Herren sehr geehrte
Mister Lauterbach ich lasse nicht locker
und spreche hier nochmals die MDR die
medical device Regulation an meine
Fraktion und ich erreichen nach wie vor
zahlreiche besorgte Anfragen nachdem es
zu Beginn in erster Linie viele kleine
und mittelständische Unternehmen waren
wenden sich jetzt vor allem Ärzte und
Patienten an uns die befürchten von der
derzeitigen
genehmigungssituation massiv negativ
betroffen zu sein Patienten befürchten
dass die für sie wichtige
Medizinprodukte nicht mehr verfügbar
sind Ärzte befürchten gravierende
Konsequenzen bis hin zu
lebensbedrohlichen Situationen ihrer
Patienten über ihnen schwebt das Schwert
der Haftungsrecht in Konsequenzen wenn
sie wegen nicht Verfügbarkeit
eingeführter Produkte auf Ersatzlösungen
Ausweichen nach wie vor ist nicht
geklärt wie rund 25.000 Zertifizierung
bis zum Ende der Übergangsperiode im Mai
24 ausgestellt werden sollen
wenn jetzt nichts unternommen wird und
ich betone jetzt
verschwinden bei bis zu 40% der derzeit
noch genutzten Produkte vom Markt meine
Damen und Herren
die Zeit Rennen uns davon
Herr Minister sie müssen jetzt handeln
oder wie mein Kollege Tino Sorge
richtigerweise bemerkt hat kommen sie
endlich ins Handeln sie müssen jetzt
Zwischenfrage aus der SPD-Fraktion danke
sehr nein danke sie müssen jetzt
gegenüber der EU aktiv werden sonst
verlieren wir geschätzt 10 %
insbesondere der kleinen
mittelständischen Unternehmen und zu
viele der zugelassene Medizinprodukte
vor allem wichtige Nischenprodukte Herr
Minister ich stehe immer weniger
verstehe immer weniger warum Sie und Ihr
Haus die bei dieser überaus wichtigen
Frage nicht massiv in Säuglingen meine
Damen und Herren ein weiteres wichtiges
Thema bildet sich im Haushalt nicht ab
ich meine nochmals an dass die Regierung
uns erklärt hat umfassende
Präventionsmaßnahmen ergreifen zu wollen
nur mit Prävention und Aufklärung können
wir Krebserkrankungen Bluthochdruck die
Volkskrankheiten Diabetes mellitus und
Adipositas schon vor schon vor der
Entstehung in gegentreten es muss dein
Urin im ureigenen Interesse der
Gesundheitspolitik liegen der
Bevölkerung vor allem auch den Kindern
Jugendlichen noch vorentstehung dieser
Krankheiten
Präventionsangebote zu machen meine
Damen und Herren der Koalition ihre vier
beschworene
fortschrittskoalition versagt hier mehr
als jämmerlich die Haushaltsentwurf
lehnen wir ab herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Präsident dass sie das
Zulassen schade Herr Kollege monstadt
dass sie das nicht in der ihre Rede
zugelassen haben man kann über die MDR
sicherlich viele sagen aber dass sie
hier sagen
dass wir große Probleme haben stimmt
einfach so nicht das ist eine Lüge es
kommen mittlerweile in Firmen auf mich
zu und auf unsere Fraktion die bereits
zertifiziert sind und dadurch Nachteile
sehen zu denen die noch nicht im
Verfahren sind man kann sicherlich sagen
es hat gedauert die benannten Stellen
haben noch zu tun aber jetzt den
Eindruck zu erwecken es wäre alles
schlecht das ist einfach nicht wahr
[Applaus]
Frau Kollegin da muss ich Ihnen leider
massiv widersprechen ich weiß nicht wo
sie diese Informationen her haben uns
erreichen andere das Gegenteil ist
richtig im benannten Stellen sind zu
wenig das Personal bei den benannten
Stellen ist nicht ausreichend
dimensioniert und der Aufwand der
erzeugt wurde durch die MDR hat sich
verfügfacht das muss bedeuten dass wir
nicht genug Kapazitäten haben diese
Produkte zuzulassen und dann haben wir
gerade das Problem und das haben sie
glaube ich bis heute nicht verstanden
dass vor allen Dingen die Produkte die
keine Umsätze machen Nischenprodukte wo
seltenerkrankungen mit behandelt werden
dass die nicht mehr am Markt verfügbar
sind weil die Unternehmen das Geld nicht
einsetzen können um hier eine
Zertifizierungsprozess zu durchlaufen
von daher ist es geboten und Herr
Minister ich kann sie noch mal nur
auffordern dieses geboten in Brüssel zu
intervenieren dass wir dort zu einer
Regelung kommen sonst gehen die Produkte
vom Markt und dann kann man auch sie
nicht wollen danke
so das Wort hat Flügel der Kollege
Matthias David SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
guten Tag liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
mehr Fortschritt Wagen das ist nicht nur
der Leitsatz unserer bunten Koalition
nein es zeigt sich heute ganz konkret
auch im Haushalt für Gesundheit denn wir
setzen ganz klare Prioritäten auf
digitale Lösungen für die Versorgung
unserer Patienten und Patienten und ich
möchte zwei ganz konkrete Beispiele
hervorheben die für besonders wichtig
halte das erste Beispiel sind die
zusätzlichen Mittel um die Thematik zur
digitalen gesundheitsagentur
weiterzuentwickeln das ist wichtig denn
diese digitale Agentur braucht ein ganz
klaren Auftrag nämlich die Nutzenden
viel stärker in den Fokus zu nehmen wenn
neue Anwendungen und Produkte im
Gesundheitswesen entwickelt werden und
dieser Auftrag muss hinterlegt werden
mit Mitteln klaren Strukturen und
Prozessen um von Anfang an
sicherzustellen dass neue digitale
Anwendung auch so funktionieren dass sie
einfach und stabil in der Praxis laufen
das zweite Thema was ich erwähnen will
ist wir werden Mittel bereitstellen um
die Datenlage zu verbessern ein Beispiel
dafür ist dass wir das Notaufnahme
Register in die Krankenhaus zu wählen
aufnehmen werden was bedeutet das das
heißt ganz konkret dass wir einen
besseren Überblick mehr Transparenz
haben werden über die
Behandlungskapazitäten in unseren
Kliniken und das sind ganz konkrete
Fortschritte wo wir bessere Daten für
bessere Entscheidungen bekommen werden
mir Geld alleine wird allerdings nicht
ausreichen um die Digitalisierung
voranzubringen sondern wir werden auch
die Baustellen angehen müssen wovon
einer unwidersprochen die digitale
Patientenakte ist die digitale
Patientenakte braucht ein umfassendes
Update damit sie am Ende auch Mehrwerte
bringt und zwar für alle für die Breite
der Bevölkerung und vor allem auch
diejenigen entlastet die in den Kliniken
arbeiten in den Praxen die in das
alltägliche Arbeiten einfacher macht das
wird noch ein dickes Brett nur wir
müssen mal alle anpacken nicht nur der
Minister und die Ampelkoalition sondern
auch alle die dazugehören rund um
Datenschutz und Sicherheit nur wenn man
das gemeinsam anpacken bekommen hat es
auch hin
diese zusätzlichen Budgets und des
angehen dieser dicken Bretter sind nicht
selbstverständlich und deshalb will ich
einmal diejenigen ansprechen die das
wirklich ernsthaft angehen und diese
Budgets bereitgestellt haben und das ist
vorneweg unser engagierter Minister
Lauterbach mit seinen verdammt hart
arbeitender Mannschaft im Ministerium
das sind unsere
durchsetzungs-
und das sind unsere progressiv
aufgestellten Fraktion an all diejenigen
will ich einmal sagen Danke schön für
diesen Rückenwind damit war aus dem
Leitsatz mehr Fortschritte waren auch
Realität machen besten Dank
Erich irrsdorf für die cdu/csu ist
Mitglied im Gesundheitsausschuss der
Bundestag debattiert immer noch über den
Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen erlauben Sie mir zwei Punkte
bevor ich auf den Haushalt eingehe das
Thema Pflege Bonus ich kann nur die
Meinung von Herrn natürlich auch von
Tino Sorge teilen wir bekommen da extrem
viele Zuschriften und deshalb verstehe
ich das so Herr Minister wir bündeln das
ganze und wir lassen Ihnen das zukommen
und dann schauen wir doch ob da etwas zu
machen ist und zum Nachbessern ist
erster Punkt
zweiter Punkt Frau lützke sie haben das
Thema Cannabis angesprochen ich muss
Ihnen hier einfach widersprechen weil es
in meinen Augen inhaltlich falsch ist
wenn sie in der Ampel hergehen und
Kinder und Jugendliche vor Zucker
schützen wollen und somit Schokoriegel
und alles was dazugehört aus den
kassenräumen verbannen und gleichzeitig
Cannabis legalisieren kann ich nur sagen
das ist falsch das ist inhaltlich falsch
und deshalb wäre es gut wenn Sie die
bayerischen Vorschläge sich hier noch
mal zuhören aber jetzt zum Haushalt
gerade in Krisenzeiten braucht ihr einen
soliden Haushalt und eine solide
Haushaltspolitik und im
Gesundheitsbereich zeigt sich Sachen
noch viel mehr die Pandemie hat
verdeutlicht dass unsere Finanzstärke an
vielen Stellen hier auch helfen konnten
die corona-pandemie haben wir
größtenteils gut und ordentlich und auch
bedächtigt bewältigt und jedoch braucht
es zum Ende einer
die Gesundheitskrise in meinen Augen
auch immer einen kritischen Blick auf
das was finanziert und was ausgegeben
wurde und ich finde es als gut und ich
finde es auch als richtig dass man
hierhergeht und im Bereich der
longkowitz-hilfen dass man die natürlich
auch ausbaut dass man hier auf Beratung
setzt dass man hier in diese Richtung
auch weitergeht dass man long mit Post
mit all diese Dinge nicht unter den
Tisch fallen lässt und dass man hier
drauf sitzt 614.000 Euro sind hier
zeitlich begrenzt und das digitales
Beratungsangebot ist das hier mit dabei
ich möchte aber auch darauf hinweisen
dass wir hier in diesem Bereich wenn es
zum Langzeitfolgen geht natürlich auch
eine Erkrankung haben die im Endeffekt
die Königsdisziplin von Long koved ist
das ist nachgewiesen das ist einfach
auch mit CSS und ich möchte hier einen
Dank aussprechen
dass man hier diese Überlappung der
beiden Haushalte 22 und 23 mein Dank
hier an die Minister an die ampler
natürlich auch an Helge braun der uns
das sehr gut vertreten hat und das auch
transportiert hat möchte ich Dank sagen
dass man hier diese Mittel für die
Forschung für mecfs dass man das ganze
hier übertragen konnte dieses richtig
das war notwendig und das ist gut
erlauben Sie mir aber auch dass ich
natürlich mein
magenthema Pflege hier bin verwende
einfach und ich möchte ich erwähnen und
ich möchte Ihnen ganz klar sagen dass
wir das Thema Finanzierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung der
Pflege für Versicherung
krankenhausreform und alles was dazu
gehört natürlich anpassen dass sie
unterstützen wir auch aber ich möchte
schon darauf hinweisen dass wir auch den
Bereich der Leiharbeit hier sehr
kritisch einfach mal ins Visier nehmen
müssen so glaube ich geht das nicht
weiter und wir haben hier in diesem Land
steigende Ausbildungszahlen das ist gut
das ist richtig und das ist notwendig
aber wir wissen auch dass die
Auszubildenden in dieser Relation gar
nicht so stark steigen können wieder
Bedarf noch Pflege steigt deshalb müssen
wir hier in die Tat kommen das ist das
entscheidende und ich bitte auch darum
wie wir diskutieren ja immer wieder auch
das Thema Energie
und alles was dazu gehört ich kann Ihnen
nur sagen das Thema Krankenhäuser Kinder
und Jugendpflege Altenpflege und vor
allem auch die Reha hier müssen wir
handeln wir dürfen jetzt Strukturen
nicht zerstören die wir auch nach den
Krisen wieder brauchen das ist notwendig
und deshalb plädiere ich da auch dafür
letzter Punkt den ich mir hier
vorgenommen habe noch zu erwähnen ist
dass wir natürlich Differenzierung auch
brauchen nicht nur auf Franco wird auf
eine CFS und all diese Dinge sagen dass
es viele seltene Erkrankungen gibt die
wir auch in den Mittelpunkt unseres
Handels stellen müssen und von da ist es
mir wichtig dass wir hier diese 7000
Erkrankungen die wir in Deutschland
kennen und haben wir haben hier vier
Millionen Patientinnen und Patienten
dass wir die nicht unversorgt lassen
hier müssen wir besser werden hier warte
ich natürlich auch Bewegung dass wir in
diese Richtung handeln können wir werden
in Bayern hier ein Jahr das selten
Erkrankungen 2023 in den wegleiten und
ich würde mich freuen wenn meine
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
fraktionsübergreifend hier auch tätig
werden wenn wir über 700 Abgeordneten
sind jeder eine seltene macht dann
glaube ich haben wir schon einiges
erreicht in diesem Sinn herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank
Kirsten kapatonter von den Bündnisgrünen
ist die stellvertretende Vorsitzenden
Gesundheitsausschuss und sie kommt von
den Grünen
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Besucherinnen auf den
tribünenberatungen über den Haushalt
kommen oft sehr trocken daher doch diese
Finanzentscheidungen haben das Zeug dazu
den Alltag vieler ganz konkret zu
verbessern und gut das im
gesundheitsetat hier viel erreicht
werden konnte
es ist notwendig die seelische
Gesundheit zentrale und ich sage
ausdrücklich deutlich zentraler als
bisher in den Blick zu nehmen jede von
ihnen kennt mindestens eine Person die
schon mal eine seelische Krise erlebt
hat und viele mögen auch selbst schon
einmal betroffen gewesen sein und kennen
die Hürden der Schnittstellenprobleme
wichtig ist dass alle Betroffenen die
passgenauen Hilfen bekommen und dafür
finanzieren wir jetzt den Psychiatrie
Dialog im Psychiatrie Dialog werden
Versorgungsangebote für seelisch
erkrankte Menschen weiterentwickelt
und ich freue mich dass die Aktion
psychisch Kranke hier erneut die
Koordination übernehmen wird akute Hilfe
bietet der krisenchat der schnellen Rat
für Kinder und Jugendliche in Krisen
ermöglicht auch hierfür konnten in den
Haushaltsberatungen der Fraktionen noch
mittelfrei geschaufelt werden und es ist
so unser Seele unsere Seele steht
angesichts der multiplen sich ja auch
überlappenden Krisen der Klimakrise
Corona Preissteigerung Krieg deutlich
unter Druck Prävention gute Vorsorge
statt warten bis es zu spät ist ist ein
wichtiges Leitprinzip gerade wenn es um
Gesundheit geht
und ist es ein wichtiger es ist ein
wichtiger erster Schritt dass die
Aufstockung der Mittel für den
nationalen präventionsplan auch ein
Konzept für die Suizidprävention enthält
jetzt muss freilich der zweite Schritt
folgen es braucht niedrigschwellige
Angebote zur Suizidprävention für alle
Altersgruppen online telefonisch vor Ort
auch diese müssen natürlich künftig
finanziert werden und auch es ist ja
schon mehrfach angesprochen worden die
Suchtprävention für die Suchtprävention
konnten die verschwundenen vier
Millionen Euro wieder aufgestockt werden
auf insgesamt 13,2 Millionen und ich
sage ausdrücklich das muss jetzt aber
auch mal so bleiben
wer an der Prävention spart der Zahl
später doppelt das wissen wir und Herr
Elsdorfer ich widerspreche ihn
ausdrücklich die Legalisierung von
Cannabis die verbessert die Prävention
und den Gesundheitsschutz die Projektion
die schadet und als die cdu/csu noch die
Drogenbeauftragte gestellt hat haben
sich Jugendliche und Fachleute
überglückten Kampagnen lustig gemacht es
wird Zeit für sachliche Informationen
und für wirksame Prävention ich freue
mich dass auch hierfür im Haushalt
Gelder vorgesehen werden würde ich
ergänze next step Gesetzentwurf vielen
Dank fürs zuhören
das Wort den fraktionslosen Abgeordneten
Robert fahren der nächste Redner Robert
farle ist im September aus der AFD
ausgetreten er ist einer von
mittlerweile sechs fraktionslosen
Abgeordneten 5 davon stammen aus der
afd-fraktion der 6 ist dort nie
eingetreten
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
erstens im Rahmen der
corona-pandemie die jetzt hinter uns
liegt
fanden groß angelegte Täuschungsmanöver
statt
verbunden mit politischer Korruption und
offenen Rechtsbrüchen zum Zwecke einer
gigantischen
vermögensumverteilung zur Gunsten der
großen Pharmakonzerne und einzelner
Privatpersonen teilweise sogar
Abgeordneten im Bundestag
Janine small
hat in einer Anhörung der EU klar
ausgeführt das vor der Zulassung der
mnra
Impfstoffe nicht getestet worden ist ob
diese überhaupt eine Übertragung des
Virus vermeiden können und nicht
getestet und untersucht worden ist ob
die überhaupt eine Weitergabe dieser
Viren verhindern können diese Impfung
und diese Lüge war die Grundlage für die
gesamten Impfkampagnen seit Beginn
dieser des letzten und vorletzten Jahres
das müssen wir mal vor gewährt werden
das ist so wahr zweitens das Bleibende
Resultat staatlicher pandemiebekämpfung
seit april
2021 sind
übersterblichkeitsraten von bis zu 20
Prozent in allen
stark durchgeimpften westlichen Staaten
der eigentliche Skandal besteht darin
dass die Gesundheitsminister dieses
Landes und eben auch jetzt Herr
Lauterbach bis heute nicht dafür gesorgt
haben dass die Ursachen dieser
Übersterblichkeit aufgeklärt sind das
ist eine solche Übersterblichkeit da
sind so viele Menschen bei gestorben und
zwar es gibt keine andere Erklärung als
die hohe Durchimpfung der Bevölkerung
dass sie mit den Impfungen dann lesen
Sie die Kampagne durch lesen Sie was
Professor Kubaner und andere
rausgefunden haben mit ihren
statistischen Überprüfung damit
beschäftigen sie sich gar nicht und
kommen noch nicht mal auf die Idee
obwohl diese Übersterblichkeit sehr
viele Menschen betrifft
sehr geehrte Herr Lauterbach sie haben
im Herbst diesen Jahres noch 830
Millionen Euro Steuergelder
vernichtet sie haben 80 Millionen
Impfdosen von moderner gekauft die
demnächst entsorgt werden müssen immer
mehr Ärzte weigern sich diese
gefährlichen und nicht immunisierenden
Impfungen zu verabreichen und genauso
soll es 2023 weitergehen da wollen sie
weitere 2,9 Milliarden Euro für kurvit
Impfstoffe ausgeben um die Profite der
Pharmakonzerne hochzuhalten das ist
reine Lobby-Politik dazu noch eine
völlig sinnfreie 60 Millionen Euro teure
Fake News Werbekampagne
die gewählte die nicht gewählte
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen hat per SMS 4,2 Milliarden
Impfdosen also zehn Dosen pro EU-Bürger
bestellt die europäische
Staatsanwaltschaft EPO ermittelt bereits
hinzukommt Herr Kollege ich habe Ihnen
soeben das Wort entzogen weil sie meiner
hinreichenden bitte zur Ende zu kommen
nicht folgen 35 Sekunden geredet seit
bereits überzogen sie dürfen sich jetzt
setzen
[Applaus]
Robert Vahle tut überrascht allerdings
muss ich zugeben ich habe heute auch das
Gefühl dass der Präsident etwas leiser
rüberkommt als man es sonst so hat also
ich habe es auch nur kaum verstanden
aber in der Tat ist die Zeit abgelaufen
da lohnt sich auch keine Diskussion Erle
nimmt hoffentlich jetzt gleich Platz
damit weitergehen kann und in diesem
Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit ist die letzte
Rednerin von der SPD Tina Rudolf sie ist
ob Frau im Unterausschuss globale
Gesundheit
herr Präsident ich ersetze darauf dass
sie so kulant dann bei meiner Fraktion
und mir demnächst auch mit den
Redezeiten sind und zu guten Ton in
Debatten gehört es natürlich auch dass
man kurz auf Vorrednerinnen und
Vorredner eingeht das schaffe ich jetzt
nicht bei der Rede nicht in Gänze ich
investiere zehn Minuten und ganz zehn
Sekunden um kurz was zu überstertigkeit
zu sagen die habe ich nicht ähm da ist
im Jahr 2020 bereits auch schon eine
große Übersterblichkeit gab in einem
Jahr in dem wir noch keine Impfung
hatten würde ich jetzt mal sagen liegt
der Zusammenhang relativ nah dass die
Tode vielleicht doch eher mit der
Pandemie zu tun haben wer seit diesem
Jahr 2020 sehen und die Impfung nach wie
vor gegen diese Pandemie schützt und ist
deswegen eine der vielen halb und
Unwahrheiten war die in diesem
Zusammenhang heute verbreitet worden
sind ich möchte jetzt aber tatsächlich
noch über Gesundheit reden und über das
Menschenrechte auf Gesundheit das
wichtig ist
die Weltgesundheitsorganisation hat 1946
in ihrer Präambel das Modell von
Gesundheit als
biopsychosoziales Modell geprägt das
bedeutet das Gesundheit mehr ist als die
Abwesenheit von Krankheit gesundheit ist
ein vollständiges körperliches geistiges
und soziales Wohlbefinden
und dieser Anspruch den die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation da
formuliert hat und den wir versuchen
gerecht zu werden auch mit unserer
Politik der kann manchmal ein sehr
großer sein gerade wenn es um globale
Gesundheit geht gerade wenn es um all
das geht was wir eigentlich gerade
global auch tun müssen es ist auch in
Deutschland so dass im Winter wieder
Menschen draußen in der Kälte schlafen
werden es ist auch in Deutschland so
dass wir viele Menschen haben die de
facto keine Krankenversicherung haben
weil sie sich in Tarifen versichert
sehen wo sie weniger Zugang zu gesunden
zum Gesundheitssystem haben das in
Deutschland sich Menschen und Papiere
nicht zur Gesundheitsberatung und zur
Gesundheitsversorgung trauen weil sie
Angst davor haben und dass das etwas ist
was aber auch global uns immer noch vor
die Aufgabe stellt dass wir es nicht
schaffen allen Menschen auch Zugang zu
wirklich basaler Medizin zu ermöglichen
die eigentlich finanziell sehr sehr gut
zu erreichen wäre weil es sich eben
teilweise nicht lohnt in die Erforschung
von
also vernachlässigten Krankheiten zu
investieren weil die Aussicht besteht
dass man damit eben nicht so viel Profit
machen kann und das meine Damen und
Herren muss uns immer wieder vor Augen
führen dass es unsere Aufgabe ist nicht
allein als Deutschland aber gemeinsam
mit der internationalen Gemeinschaft
auch im Bereich der globalen Gesundheit
zu investieren
und Liebe Union ich glaube und und weiß
und das will ich Ihnen in keiner Weise
in Abrede stellen dass Sie also wir
gemeinsam in den letzten Jahren dafür
gesorgt haben dass der Bereich der
globalen Gesundheit sehr gut finanziert
wurde jetzt gehört aber zu weit
natürlich auch dass wir heute und hier
vor einer Situation stehen wo die
haushaltsverhandlung schwierige sind wo
die Gesamtsituation eine andere ist wo
wir uns insgesamt mit so vielen
konfrontiert sehen was wir eigentlich
finanziell bewältigen müssen dass mich
unglaublich froh und dankbar sind dass
die Haushälterinnen und Haushälter
unserer Koalition geschafft haben im
Gegensatz zum eigentlich vorgelegten
Entwurf noch so viel für die globale
Gesundheit rauszuholen und dass wir es
vor allem schaffen die wichtigen
Strukturen weiter zu finanzieren unter
anderem ähm wurde genannt existiert 19
Todes excelulator wo wir auch die
Finanzierung bis 2023 haben wo es aber
auch darum geht so etwas auf nachhaltige
Füße zu stellen und es ist eben nicht
nur so dass ich das nicht nur im
Haushalt des
Bundesgesundheitsministeriums befindet
sondern uns ja auch gelungen ist zum
Beispiel die kernbeiträge der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation zu erhöhen
und das ist das wichtige Zeichen dass
ich am Ende setzen möchte darum muss es
gehen dass wir global solidarisch
finanzieren auch um das Ansehen der
weltgesundheitssituation der Gesundheit
zu gehen vielen Dank
danke
[Applaus]
schließlich die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den Einzelplan 15
Bundesministerium für Gesundheit in der
ausschussfassung wer stimmt für die
einzigen 15 Jahre
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen wer
stimmt dagegen
jetzt muss ich sagen das sind die
übrigen Fraktionen des Hauses weil der
Fraktions
zu sprechen also übrigens